four
three
two
what is up h3 podcast family
it's monday baby may 16th
today's episode is sponsored by
hellofreshman mobileandstamps.com
we love you so much thank you
uh we have an amazing show
today ab is back in the building
gotta say it's nice to have you sitting
there
i didn't realize how much how much many
times i turned to the left when i'm
saying something
and my eyes all frequently fall on you
or dan and when that seat was empty it
kind of it kind of [ __ ] me up a little
bit because i was like [ __ ] well i'm
back baby i don't know something about
having an audience that uh
i always laugh at your jokes
you know
yeah i smile a lot that's in the
contract yeah it's in our employment
engagement yeah
so i appreciate that
welcome back oh is that poor zach's not
here today man um poor zach
why do you say it like that
we have a little
conspiracy theory going on here really
zack's illness
okay
you know that zach is supposed to go uh
meet up with jimmy lee tomorrow bro i
had that same exact thought immediately
we spoke to him on the phone and he was
kind of coughing like derrick's defender
yeah so he called in thick today he says
he has died he's puking and diarrhea and
stuff is that what he said mm-hmm
because he i think he's just playing to
my
my weaknesses because he knows mm-hmm
that's my stick yeah but um
i don't think he's lying no i'm just
kidding it's funny though i think he's
funny because he has this meeting with
jimmy lee tomorrow yeah so
i get it man you know
zach described his last outing with
jimmy lee as the worst day of his life
so i definitely get it if you want to if
you want to fake an illness zack i
totally get it
i'm not even going to hate so there's
his empty chair
dan you're going to be doing sound bites
today
uh to a very very limited extent because
i have about uh six here on my uh little
mini sound you want to play all six
first let's just see what we can expect
all at once no no one at a time
[Applause]
that's actually zach stuttering on a
loop play it well
that's what happens when you fall in
sick you just get roasted the whole time
uh okay well
um
well we're back we're here you know i
had such a great time
to everybody who couldn't make the
members
stream
uh we had such a great time
it's if you are a member and you want to
watch it it's still up
but again we're just watching the
creator clash
and uh we had a good time man jello
shots pizza
we watched the f the fights were amazing
i gotta say man that event
was
to anyone who didn't watch it and to
those who did but
first of all shout out to anissa
and idubbbz and apparently the game
grumps aaron hansen's uh production
company companies the one that put it on
yeah yeah because the production was
like so professional i was like ryan
kavanagh eat your heart out a youtuber
just put on a better event than you you
[ __ ] loser absolutely
and i bet you for a lot lot less money
too
he lost 100 a billion dollars last year
actually only 800 million
uh you're rounding down let's stick to
the facts here it's 820 million i think
okay 820 million yes be precise if you
want to brown down
so
fights do are we able to or can we show
clips what do we think i think we can
show clips in the context of our
conversation i mean i'm fighting a
lawsuit for the right to do it
so
you've got to stand by my
my
i could confirm if you'd like if you
want me to
sure you can ask but that but that's not
the point right right thank you other
fighters been sharing it yeah so where
can i pull up um i want to get clips of
first of all dad
the dad fight was insane he went first
and you know we had dad versus matt
watson on
and dad was like i'm gonna kill him
i'm gonna murder him he even brought a
body bag with his name on it that wasn't
a joke he actually brought it to the
fight and i'll tell you what matt watson
was close to needing that body bag
because that was the fastest fight by
far
dad came out swinging and just i felt
bad for matt man he never get to throw a
punch he was just like yeah i was
overwhelmed by the ultimate weapon dad
pure uh massacre uh i just sent you a
clip of uh
oh you got a couple there there's no the
first one actually has our uh stream
reacting to it okay that's cool so this
was the first fight we just arrived
i sat down i was like okay you know i
knew dad versus matt watson was going to
be a good one
all right so um
it's okay oh you oh oh that is called oh
my god
dad like hates matt
[Music]
didn't you like holy [ __ ] did you get to
see that fight maybe from where you were
i did and it made me want to change my
strategy
yeah and yeah it messed with me a little
bit
well the fights were were pretty great i
gotta say the the fights were pretty
gruesome man yeah like
i gotta say the quality of the fights
was incredible
every single person that stepped into
that ring was a warrior i mean everyone
put up such an incredible fight
all good sportsmanship all the way
around except for dr mike which i'm
going to talk about but you know what i
might i don't want to [ __ ] on dr mike i
respect the
i respect the uh
the tournament
i respect the the event too much but i
will i will throw a little shade at dr
mike respectfully
you know i got a little bit of a man
crush on dr mike after meeting him i
gotta say
sure he yeah well you sure yeah i mean
he's beautiful right he's he's but like
he's too perfect right he was really
mine yeah it's a little sus
i was saying on the live stream that he
you know he [ __ ]
uh
human skulls
and because he's a doctor he can do all
kinds of weird [ __ ] to them
well he was really nice to me he sent a
nice video to my aunt who's a big fan of
his um your aunt's a big fan of dr mike
okay
i says because he's a doctor he can like
uh numb you can like surgically open a
hole in their head and numb their brain
and then just like literally [ __ ] them
to death
which knows what the hamilktor does
right
did hannibal do that with his penis yeah
well i guess he would hate him he hate
the brain no mike that's not enough to
satisfy mike okay he needs to take it
further got it
mike probably he probably takes it all
off and then eats it afterwards you know
what i'm saying
yeah
anyway
um
so that was the first fight
and then what was the lineup again that
was amazing and then i think the next
really memorable one if you do you guys
remember the line i think the next one
was alex first ryan yes alex versus ryan
was such an insane fight
those guys are such warriors and you
know i heard from abe
behind the scenes that alex was a
was a
machine right alex is and he looked good
he was strong yeah me and alex got close
throughout this whole process we talked
a lot on the phone we were supposed to
spar for months and we just never got
around to it and i was watching that
fight i'm like thank god thank god i
never sparred with alex because that guy
is a killer he is yeah so going into
that i was like alec or ryan mcgee is
gonna get murdered
but that dude he went the distance
didn't he oh yeah ryan had a lot of
heart i
everyone in the locker room was like
cheering for both of them like they
couldn't believe that the fight was
still going on i i was cheering for ryan
so much
even though i knew alex was pro was
going to win at the end but
listen that that dude ryan
he made up big time for because he's
partners with matt watson they're the
super mega guys right
and uh he he landed some mean punches on
alex you know
and uh boy that was that was just a a
war man those guys are are warriors i
don't know what else to say and you know
things were i mean this was like
there was lots of blood and a lot of the
fights i mean it was a real fight dude
these people were
not messing around
just give you a little highlight
who's gonna take this did ryan break his
nose his face was pretty messed up
honestly this whole fight was a
highlight it was a long one and it was a
great one so both those guys are
incredible is alex ernst religious or
something because i saw someone say
something about
i don't remember the comment but i was
like i saw what you're talking about
ryan tweeted a thing
a picture of himself getting punched by
him and he said when when alex ernst
finds out that you had pre-marital sex
yeah
was that a i don't know if that's just a
super mega meme or if that's uh or if
that's some reference to alex ernst
being religious i i don't know
but you know what
so much respect for both those guys
uh wow true warriors and then let's see
the next fight
oh here here's ryan uh after the fight
you know
shout out ryan mcgee man you're you got
a warrior's heart bro
he really does i was so impressed with
him
so there you have it people saying it's
a super mega meme oh it is okay okay
because i was
that was i guess that's what people feel
like when they watch this show without
any context you know
so true so then after those two fought
that was one of my favorite fights for
the record the whole night was was
incredible
oh yeah there's internet comment
etiquette versus dj grape juice which i
call him his name cj welsh
i mean shout out to eric i think he's
been he was just chain smoking i don't
think he was ready for the heat and dj
grape juice was definitely brought the
heat so that was a fun fight just
because
i'm a fan of eric
eric's the man i'm so thankful eric was
there like we stuck together the whole
time it was he's a great guy yeah he is
just a great guy and we found out that
dj welsh is uh his family yeah he's
family yeah i know i was like uh i was
so torn i was like listen it's family
versus family out here but i had to go
with my boy eric i mean he's a friend
it's so funny how many people like
whispered in my ear like family
i love that bj
i've heard you guys are both nice guys
but honestly then the day i hope you win
and then he whispers like family
wow love that and then the next fight
was the odds one out who's an animator
first i did a thing i'm not familiar
with i didn't think
apparently sam's a fan he's a makes
science videos
this guy's a lean murderer i don't even
know what to say about that fight
i did a thing just came out and
pulverized
uh the poor odds went out that was
probably the only like i would just say
not bad fight but it was just
well and then there's dad but it was
just it wasn't you know it was just a it
was a murder yeah well i did a thing
he's like he's like perfect
he's tall
who could even beat him i mean
i might say perfect physical condition i
just said he's perfect he's perfect he's
really nice
he's really nice he's so dreamy the next
fight was incredible it was uh just a
minks versus yodeling haley
that fight was off the rails yeah that
fight was incredible you know
both those ladies just fought their
hearts out yeah
and it was it was kind of a bloodblast
because yodeling haley said she doesn't
even remember the fight she got clocked
a lot but she landed something good she
clarified later that she didn't mean
from like concussion memory loss just
that the the nerves and the adrenaline
okay okay made it a blur yeah
that was one of my favorite fights those
those ladies were incredible yeah uh
what a it was a great fight and then we
come to
hundar of muscle party versus h a b of
the h3 podcast
and to talk about this we have a special
guest
me nope not you
nope not you
sam i'm serious oh no really yeah okay
it's honda
[Applause]
so wait where where are they sitting dan
oh okay
so honda
what's up dude you look huge in person
so
he looks bigger in person so oh shredder
be cool be cool
better shorter shredder
better shredder stop
shredder wants a piece of the action
hello
so uh joining us is abey's of uh
opponent hundar now this fight was an
incredible fight
um
you guys can scoot over a little bit
more
get close so i'm going to smell you
sandwiches take a bath before i came
here so appreciate it should be pleasant
so first of all honda the ultimate
sportsman
a class act a gentleman all the way you
know
such a uh hyundai ultimately won the
fight but at a great it was a great
battle
it was a it was like a a good technical
fight i would say compared to the other
ones for sure you guys had your hands up
you were fighting you both got a knock
down which was which was really
interesting yeah which i don't think any
other fight had
that kind of uh back and forth
the trade i missed half the fights
because after our fight i was just on
the ground yeah five minutes trying to
catch my brother yeah five minutes five
hours trying to catch my breath so yeah
uh we showed do we have that clip i mean
ab was in the back with the oxygen tank
this is the closest they've been to you
since we've been clenching brothers this
is wild
[Laughter]
uh yes i have the clip for uh one second
also if we have some highlights
send me that clip i want to show a
hundred speech too but that's all in the
dock oh it is yep
um
let's see
let's see abey's entrance from the
stands
got that teddy fresh robe
yes yes
[Music]
wait did you edit this
oh that's the music
what was your walk in music because we
had that volume really though
oh my god bro really i'm from detroit
you did mom's
spaghetti you walked out to mom's
spaghetti very relatable oh my god i
wish i knew that
mom's spaghetti he's ready
bones is bad yeah so amy walked out
looking good mom's spaghetti
[Music]
so um
you guys were fi so how was the fight
from your guys's perspective between the
two of you guys he's a big guy amy so
i'm i'm definitely feeling the
where do we start i don't remember most
of it to be honest yeah like when you
think haley said that she didn't
remember in the moment so yeah i
remember certain moments i remember when
uh i fell over i remember when he fell
over
but
i remember the ending but i don't i
don't know i remember him making some
scary faces
yeah bro i had to like i don't know it
was so weird for me because we kept
running into each other like non-stop
before yeah was it awkward to see him
before the fight you just like you don't
know when you're gonna turn on like the
okay you're my opponent switch like i
don't want to be like
just glaring at you on the bus you know
it just feels unnatural right so we were
at the arena like right before the fight
we were still making jokes with each
other like you were like you were like
let's get this out of the way now yeah
no i was like we i saw him right outside
the locker room and he's being
interviewed i'm like [ __ ] it let's just
do this now yeah
yeah but i so that just being able to
walk out yeah i had to go like method
kind of honestly it would have been too
weird it was very intimidating
i was just surprised how calm i was
because i was just so afraid about it
for like six seven months people saying
i'm gonna die seeing pictures of you
looking so intimidating i don't know
what it is i think it's just that i've
went through so much that that day i was
just like let's just [ __ ] get it over
with so yeah a lot more calm than usual
interesting you looked i mean obviously
i was trying to make eye contact yeah
and you looked i mean you looked like
you
i i was like okay he's ready we're gonna
do this
yeah but so obviously when when you were
announced as his opponent the joke was
and everyone joke oh amy is going to get
murdered when you saw they were like i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this guy no be honest
with me i'm okay dead serious okay okay
and i i i really do feel like you owe
that because i know it's been non-stop
but i i was like it was funny right
obviously it's funny like i got a
picture of you you're gonna you're the
door
yeah yeah like of course that was funny
but
from like a serious perspective i was
just like the moment you buy into that
you're going to pay the price in that
ring if i start actually like it's not a
meme it's not just like for comedy and i
i like underestimate you yeah i would
know i was going to pay that my coach
said that he's like he's like don't look
at that don't look at stuff that's good
for you don't look at stuff that's bad
about you i saw like the other survey
it's like the underdog people's champ i
was i was like he's like don't look at
it
it creates pressure for you
right that people are expecting you to
win so you know it's like
it's kind of a lose-lose yeah yeah and
win-win for av as the underdog yeah
yeah i like i tried to start uh training
early before anyone else because i was
so intimidated by you so uh
mentioned that mean you were taking the
most serious i'm like great yeah i was i
wanted to get the jump on it but uh yeah
i guess me and you throughout the whole
thing we're
starting around the same time and
everything when we had to like the
weight thing was an issue yeah you
started right yeah definitely and i
commend you i know it was tough i'm sure
that was like i appreciate you meeting
me yeah when you did where you did so
like maybe was eating junk food and
donuts and you were not eating just yeah
going really light well i tuned into the
show once or somebody i saw a photo
where you were just like standing there
holding a plate of potatoes and you were
just eating
i don't know if that was related
some people i've seen some people
comment like oh only you know abe was
eating like [ __ ] and that affected why
he lost but in all honesty that's not
why because i i've always had a problem
with my endurance you know i didn't say
it publicly but i mean wally were always
worried about that because i wasn't an
athlete prior um and like me being
gassed out like that they had nothing to
do with uh me slamming those last few
days i really don't think you did you
know so just want to clarify this so um
i i you know i was really surprised by
the the ref called
uh the fight
in the last round i don't know how much
time was up but the fight was nearly
over
and the ref
called it for hundar
were you were you guys surprised by that
i was a little surprised um i think he
would have won either way but i wish
that we could have finished it though
like in all honesty and that may have
been my fault i don't know uh i don't
honestly don't even remember what i said
because she was asking me like why i was
leaning like that
i'm just you know and i are you she's
like are you tired are you tired i'm
like yeah
oh i don't know if like probably like
this guy yeah he's doing a call for help
right now right but matt watson said the
same thing like he didn't
he doesn't i forget what he said but he
answered and he was like oh i didn't
want it to end though it's because i
think fighters know you got to be like
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine i want to
fight yeah but she's like hey are you
okay you're like no
i was just like
right i was like completely gassed and i
was just hoping that i would just like
lean into him a little bit he wouldn't
load on me and that may save it up for
like the last 20 seconds to throw
whatever left i had just so we could
finish i just really wanted to finish
like i said i think obviously he had it
either way but i was hoping they would
have uh that makes a little bit of sense
yeah
but um i was out of it though too i
didn't even really know like they pulled
like they separated us and i looked
around and it was taking longer than
usual for us to come back and i like had
to look at my coach and i was like did
we win oh i looked at the cut man i was
like is this they're like they're like
i was like okay i didn't know either
like i didn't know i thought through the
time right now i'm like the time run out
or something they're just checking me
and the time's actually out or maybe
i don't know i don't i was confused i
was confused too i i didn't because it
didn't feel like i mean like i was
trying to do a lot of body work then too
because because of where you were but i
it wasn't like something super clear to
me right right that was it like a
finishing shot type thing yeah i think i
think ultimately abe put up a really
good defense
and uh well both i think you guys are
the least damaged of all the fighters
yeah thankfully i got this you see that
oh no i didn't see that hell yeah i got
something oh you gotta love luck
you got any scars to show no just inside
like i was in the locker room and they
had like two oxygen tanks on me yeah i
had to watch the last uh fight holding
the oxygen tank in front of the tv was
it just like your breath wouldn't
restore itself yeah
this has happened to me before i'm
sparring rarely but go through my you
just push yourself way way way too hard
yeah
breathing battery acid kind of thing
is she safe
is she all right
it's getting a little loopy too i think
[ __ ] you looking at it i still [ __ ]
you up
in front of my cousin my brother there
i'm glad you're backing dude
i got something she said i'm glad you're
back were you like just
you couldn't talk at all
i was like puking yeah just not
breathing cause i wasn't breathing so it
made me puke a little bit but uh yeah
okay
i'm sorry i'll go ahead go ahead hunter
i was gonna say i mean i could give you
some compliments i don't know if there
would be time but like yeah we got all
the time in the world
so
when i went in there right i was ready
to do a lot of jab work right that's
like in and sparring usually like i do a
lot of like fast jabs and then a lot i
love to parry and usually people will
come in they'll try to throw jabs in my
face and it just it's so fun to kind of
bully perry and then just open people up
those first two rounds you'll see i i
don't
do a lot of of that of like twos and
stuff because you were just you
you had experience you were not standing
there letting me hit you with like the
jabs as easily i had to work twice as
hard to even like make contact with you
appreciate that really good defense
wally wally told me how you'd come at me
oh
really he's gonna come strong jab slip
the jab go to his body interesting so i
tried that a few times i mean you
definitely got me a few times as well
but yeah i owe that to wally he
definitely
when you guys are punching each other
does it hurt
oh this man this man
like doesn't rattle you when you get hit
because you kind of you know you've got
gloves on you're punching you keep going
yeah have you had you sparred without
face gear before though no i have not
yet oh
does yours have the nose thing yeah
minus the nose thing okay mine mine
doesn't have the nose thing so it helped
me a little bit um just cuz like i'm
used to getting slammed in the nose like
without that but that doesn't people
kept finding ways to punch me over the
nose guard directly in my nose i don't
know if it was yeah i could see that be
like comparing you as well so that was
both your guys's first time without
headgear yeah oh [ __ ] so when we did
that trade i don't know what it felt
like on your end but i had never been
decked without the thing that landed so
cleanly on the chin and it like for me
it deleted them the moment it happened
and suddenly i was like because we both
kind of took a knee because of the hit
right yeah i saw like the ground kind of
coming up and i was like i should put my
foot down oh yeah but it just i was
tingly and
it wasn't a hit it was like the moment
after i that's interesting you shot up
real fast though i i tried i was like
what's the alternative just
yeah
no for for me um i mean you were
like when i saw you and i saw that you
you're definitely big but you're not as
uh like
scary as i thought like in terms of like
some of the guys who i fought just are
like six foot like a massive monster and
i was surprised because you you hit
harder than them i felt like maybe it
was without having muscle party dude
but um
but yeah i know when you knocked me over
in that and that moment uh that one like
i was pissed at that one because you
definitely got me with some that
i like had us
like plant my feet because i thought i
would have fell over but that one i felt
like i just i might i was off balance a
lot yeah but at the moment i definitely
felt it though okay um
but yeah that makes sense the one thing
i was like man i really wanted to go to
the end because i felt like a b had
thrown up such a good defense i was
really curious to see the scoreboard
ultimately
but uh
hundar i think you would have won too
you know definitely well deserved yeah
the pressure was on that final round for
sure to be like if there's any chance
because you bro first of all also you
were throwing hella punches you see how
much stuff i had to deflect during that
fight yeah like it got to me it's funny
because i told dan my strategy and i
said you could share it with the
audience once the fight starts and it
was funny because if you see the fight
it seems like you're doing what i plan
on doing which is kind of just defense
for the first few rounds and then unload
towards the end yeah but i think my
nerves just got to me a little bit and i
just kind of unloaded way too early and
it guessed me out but but it's scary
because when you start getting like uh
with those like loopy punches if you're
not careful then you just get stuck in
this net so like if i did i would have
to everything you threw i would have to
deflect it but then wait for it to come
back yeah a second time i was like let
me just get out of this every so it's
spooky well yeah anyway one of the great
fights hundar a great a competitor by
the way and your speech was pure class
man i'm going to play it
under one by uh the judge stopping it i
guess because avi was like please stop
the fight
he begged her in secret see that
explains it and i just want to say one
other thing i don't know about you but
the guy that was like explaining the
directions the guys who like walked up
the referee in the ring yeah i couldn't
understand the word he was saying he was
speaking something
no no i'm like i'm like he's like i'm
like what he's like he's like not your
hair or what i'm like oh yeah yeah is he
just does he just assume you know the
rules i think so i don't know did you
same thing i literally looked at my
coach and i said what did he just say
and my coach had already walked out i
was like okay yeah i had no idea what
the hell he said yeah i'm sure i'm sure
nothing important
but i get that the refs too like for all
of this and the stoppages and stuff i'm
sure from their angle it's like
one of these guys taking a serious
injury yeah so it's like i get it yeah
but it's but it's like frustrating
yo why they gotta get all the announcers
are like massive did you guys notice
that and everyone looks short but you're
not short yeah chills is just yeah can
they get some short people to [ __ ]
interview people next time that'd be
nice looking up to me yeah
thank you
is there anything you'd like to say to
him
nothing but respect to my opponent he
didn't [ __ ] make it easy from the
get-go
so am i it does look like you're dying
maybe we're in trouble for me so he held
in there five rounds baby five rounds
baby let's go
let's go bro
thank you for this war brother
congratulations
love to see it
a beautiful moment good sportsmanship
all around love to see it you know
that was what the the standout thing for
me about the event was just the
sportsmanship and the good nature of
everything was made the whole thing
really nice to watch
you know ian made an interesting point
about trying to do that from the
beginning and it's unlike the other
events i've seen which is all like
fueled by like
drama and [ __ ] you know and there wasn't
really any of that involved here
and i think the boxing uh world had a
lot more respect for this event too like
i saw one of the judges in the lobby and
saying like everyone's talking about
this event and how like
we did it the right way and how much
respect they have for everything so i
really got to hand it to ian and e stuff
yeah yeah big time yeah and we brought
you i mean the respect we had in the
ring like i always wanted to like you
know do the double-handed tap-off i know
there was some like doctor mike i got
that right
i don't care how excited you are i've
never been so excited that i'm like
let's have a look
all right so right yeah
now uh now first of all
let's just talk about the other lineups
here because i want uh
um besides the last one
there was a
dude
michael reeves versus graham stefan was
not do michael reeves is a machine did
you guys catch that fight michael has
the same coach yeah oh for real dude
michael was throwing bombs bro cardio is
he's just a hornet yeah
i felt bad for graham you know he's a
fair bit older but he also put up a good
fight but michael is just a monster man
and then probably the most absurd fight
of the night
was he uh harley
who if you've never met him he's
basically uh
he's the hound and he looks like the
hound from game of thrones he's massive
and he's strong
he used to be absolutely jacked looks
like he's slapped on the gym a little
bit but he don't look too bad
and then aaron hansen who's apparently a
big guy 6-2 but harley's like 6'5
and he just destroyed him yeah basically
that reach
yeah i thought when we first got paired
that we were like uneven but you know
seeing us now it's a lot different than
i thought but seeing them too i was like
holy okay we got to at least like what
was our actual final weight difference
right like six pounds yeah yeah it was
both but like those two when you're over
the heavyweight dude he's like 70 pound
difference bro that's a whole other
person yeah yeah like riding on your
shoulders man right but i gotta say
props to aaron for even getting in the
ring with him because
harley is a [ __ ] i was saying he's
like king david he's like a jewish
warrior of old
he'd be king or some [ __ ] yeah back in
the day
well aaron i saw on twitter was also
talking about the
in that moment of like he thought he
also was saying like if i have 15
seconds i'll take it but he wasn't
trying to like oh maybe aaron that said
that and i'm gonna get up with matt
watson because matt told me backstage in
the locker room but maybe i got the mix
up yeah i saw aaron's tweet as well okay
i think the you guys because it's your
first boxing experience you guys just
don't know like most fighters probably
know how to talk to the rap
yeah you know
and you're like drooling on yourself by
the time you're like even doing that
speech i was like
you could do anything you believe just
like bro
i felt bad because like i saw so many
fans walking out and i wanted to like
properly tell them goodbye or whatever
but i was just like
yeah
you look so beat in that clip
so the last fight was dr mike vs ian now
first of all
ian looked amazing i gotta say he was
[ __ ] he was prepared and he looked
really good and dr mike obviously is
like shredded as hell apparently he's
been boxing for 10 years ian [ __ ]
did really really good he looked great
you know
but basically i didn't i missed this but
look at this [ __ ] from doc that dr mike
pulled
now here
you know if i have one criticism i wish
they didn't start
yeah on the fight like that like i'd
like to see what the [ __ ] happening
but um
take a look
it's kind of low rest for me
so he gets like a big head shot off on
ian
because you know sportsmanship you touch
gloves you back up and you fight when
when you're both ready but
this is some [ __ ] what'd you say
about the quality dan
oh the camera people didn't expect it to
start yet yeah nobody did that that was
even the announcer comments on it
that was so dirty
like it's legal every fighter in this
fight should know that when the bell
rings and it's like okay it's like legal
come on yeah like that's surprising
really the headliner match
i mean listen to what the announcer said
oh i guess
but the announcer says like you know i
hate i don't like seeing that stuff uh
you know ian clearly wasn't ready it's
you know yeah
but yeah i i did not like that
and you know taking a punch like that at
the beginning can really
you know
affect the fight set you back right yeah
definitely
i think this is the second round i saw a
response tweet showing the other rounds
as well i think this happened
oh this was the second round i could be
wrong it happened in two rounds someone
else told me that too but i haven't seen
yeah i just just right before if you
scroll down
oh here someone said dr mike also did
this in the first
round the original video so let's see
different circumstances here four rounds
three minutes
dude chill bro
i get the feeling that dr mike is like
psycho competitive you know like like
he'll be playing like a game of pin
the tail on the donkey and [ __ ]
floor his 12 year old aunt because she
called say she's cheating or something
you know yeah yeah very sweaty for sure
well it was nerves yeah but yeah but
like you were nervous i was very nervous
i was nervous he knows better missed her
ten years of experience well he
clarified that too yeah yeah he made a
point yeah he made a point about the ten
years uh he was saying that he wasn't
like competitive ten years it was just
like boxing classes every so yeah i
didn't even try
because you pick a lane bro
anyway um
the fight was great honestly ian went
the distance
and he looked so good it's a shame he
lost because he really looked so good
like i would definitely like to see ian
fight again because
you know but mike mike had insane
stamina i mean like he did not tire yeah
that was impressive pretty rough it was
a good fight though i think it was a
really good matchup
and uh you know
dr mike won on judgment he's been a
little smug in the aftermath and bro i
didn't even [ __ ] i don't know dude i
just
i want to respect the event so
but you know what [ __ ] [ __ ] you dr mike
it's a little yeah sore winner kind of
vibe something like he retweeted uh
keemstar tweeted something like uh
he would have never lasted if apparently
it was supposed to be like three
four rounds of three minutes yeah and
they messed up
yeah and keemstar was like ian would
have never gone the distance
if uh
they didn't mess up the rounds and dr
mike retweeted that i was like [ __ ]
he had like five tweets in a row today
but it's like one it was the boxing
commission i guess for whatever reason
they thought they ruled it was like the
rest or they didn't let it happen but
and then like
okay but like you won bro yeah you won
just be humble man yeah he needed that
oh and then he i saw him in an interview
where he's like uh ian's really rattled
up backstage i hope he's okay i was like
let's stop it bro
how was your back was your backstage
hectic like getting out there i uh a
little bit
yours was uh your locker room was more
hype i heard we didn't have the fight on
for a while we couldn't find a freaking
uh laptop anywhere to watch it it was
like too hype because like oh really at
one point they came up to check my
gloves and i was like i don't have any
gloves like they hadn't given me gloves
oh so i was like trying to put my gloves
on last minute but ours was ours were
pretty calm yeah i think the most type
of thing was me like hyperventilating in
the second half yeah
yeah i feel a little bit like a traitor
right now i mean i'm definitely you know
it's no secret i'm team ian but uh i was
on the blue team with dr mike
oh you're standing you befriended him
you were nice yeah you guys want to be
respectful but you know he's [ __ ] and
you know he sedates people and puts his
penis
oh no that's just saying it's a joke
that's just me we're two different
people my my
my statements don't represent you yes
i'm the barrier i'm the baby
you're sick i'll say something nice
about dr mike um
he's handsome he's a doctor he's a great
youtube channel yeah great views
he's handsome is that really a
compliment i mean
yeah i mean it's not it's not i mean i
know a lot of doctors weren't handsome
so it's rare in that world
all right there you go dr mike you i
agree
there you have it dr mike handsome
ladies and gentlemen great personality
like go i keep going
that's debatable
anyway anyway did you was it how bad was
it for you with
with uh lucky boy not going because i
that even threw me off because of briggs
but baby's coach didn't didn't attend
yeah he wasn't able to attend
unfortunately um
you know i was worried at first but you
know i got really close with michael
briggs over uh the time and he was he he
knows his [ __ ] and he was very
respectful to like what me and wally
planned on doing and he like walking out
he's like remember what wally wanted
we're going to follow wall that's
awesome yeah yeah because some of those
guys in that world especially get really
competitive and be like no we're going
to do this even if it's i've seen it
even people like when i'm sparring
sometimes i'm like don't listen to
walleye i mean they're all friends but
uh yeah he was very respectful wally
strategy so oh that's nice of course i
wish wally was there but
it was it was okay it was a morale twist
for me because i hung out with briggs
and vegas for the whole trip and he was
like my second coach he was like you're
gonna do great and then they're like
you're gonna get
oh
no my uncle just switched sides i will
say though he didn't give me any
information uh
he was very professional about
everything so that'd be [ __ ] mega
[ __ ] up he's like yo i was watching
him yeah
this guy's wit his uh his defense on the
left this week man
what's crazy is like when i got lucky
with that one shot with you uh where i
did get you down i on the way there i
was watching documentary about muhammad
ali in the rumble in the jungle
and he like surprised everyone by
leading with the right jab because you
know usually you don't throw a right jab
if you're orthodox and uh
i had like no practice throwing my my
right hook but in that moment i
literally just thought of that
documentary i watched on the way here
and i threw a right hook and got lucky
with that so uh shout out to muhammad
ali
basically you are just like you're just
like
you guys have so much i'm a lot more
douchey than i was trying to i just i
was just trying to say that i go you
guys have so much in common you know
it's really interesting i'm the greatest
spirit with your body at that moment
i didn't know what i didn't know where
it came from i mean obviously that
happened but when i sat down in the
corner i was like i was like what did he
hit me with because because so you know
he came from a different direction and
he was like he's like you dropped your
offhand bro and i was like okay after
watching all those fights i hit you and
then i think just enough i was like oh
he fell
usually yeah cause like when you're like
training you're like train most of the
time like you're used to a left coming
usually and i feel like a lot of the
drills i ran at least like i was
i mean you should keep both hands up but
um yeah yeah there was a lot of that in
those opening matches i was just like in
my head like you get in there and then
you just like information starts leaking
out of your head yeah sometimes it sucks
to overthink um and that's why i haven't
rewatched too because like i know i
messed up on so many of the things that
i was taught um it's hard bro it's your
first fight without headgear i mean that
that's a big step so it must have been
pretty intense for both you guys in
there it's not cringe i was really
worried i was gonna re-watch it and just
be like you know when you see your
sparring footage and you're like oh god
i think you did
you guys looked like more polished than
the other fighters you both had your
hands up yeah it was a good defen it
felt like a more
closer to what you would expect from a
professional fight
a lot of the commentators were saying
stuff like that yeah it means a lot yeah
it does mean a lot that's cool and wally
was happy he [ __ ] me the next day so
that meant a lot well and quick so my
coach knows him from back in the day and
so he was disappointed because he was
like this is going to be such a cool
like confrontation i see a lucky boy
again he's in that corner and so he was
bumping yeah i made the joke that i was
really confident because at first i was
like oh i'm a wild card that's the
biggest advantage i have on you at the
moment then i found out your coach wild
card yeah i was like [ __ ] we both know
miyagido
yeah he kept me away from wild card i
guess just so we weren't constantly like
wait i was over at headway too
where i trained with wally oh right
right right there's only so many la
boxing gems so you're kind of like where
where's i was in eagle rock at headway
most of the time but i i i didn't get to
go over the wild card because i just
you'd be in the basement you should come
back sometime yeah okay well you got
spar though
you guys are both feeling relieved that
it's over oh yeah definitely definitely
well i saw you on twitter you're like
hey well maybe uh you know it's a nissa
last night she was talking to me and uh
hernia and i was just like
they're saying ian might do it again and
i was like ian should do it again man
that was some [ __ ] i wanted to see
him win yeah i don't know
i don't want to fight you though i feel
like it's already the beef is there
there was no beef ever but yeah wouldn't
it be nice to look at some other
person's face
after you i could take on anyone throw
me anyone well i was talking to ian he
wants me to fight philly deep
no really okay i was like that guy has
one spleen man i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
him he has like an organ thing he's like
you guys like his you've got all kinds
of things
no but my i don't have organ failure
i [ __ ] myself but that's not [ __ ] uh
so they were talking i'm not i'm not
fighting by the way they were talking i
told them i'll only fight ryan's toy
review or uh
or white claw game
that'd be good yeah that would be
interesting in the group chat the fire
group chat they were talking about that
and i was like i thought it was just
like a meme or whatever then i noticed
philip defranco followed me on twitter
today i was like oh [ __ ] maybe he's
serious about this maybe he's trying to
set this up well he said he said philly
is seriously considering fighting
but uh i'm not i'm not doing that
[ __ ] that
especially after watching y'all fight
that [ __ ] is intense yeah i'm an old man
you know what i mean like how old are
you i'm 38.
okay so we're similar age yeah but you
you've taken good care of yourself
so congratulations on that
what made you change your mind just
because now it's like you feel good you
feel proud it's different right i mean i
don't i sincerely i don't
i'm not leaning one way or another i
mean i was like completely i'll never do
it again but now it's like i don't know
yeah they were hyping me up a little bit
hyping both of us up you know saying
that we put on such a great show and
everyone was saying that it was really
close to a professional fight and uh i
don't know let's see there were a few
people that were like that but when
harley got to the hotel he's like nah
enough for me this will be it and then
immediately he's like dr disrespect you
[ __ ]
dude yeah i would watch harley versus
doctor disrespect i mean how do you how
do you beat harley he's literally the
dude weighs 300 pounds i mean it's nuts
yeah i would watch that doctor
disrespect is huge though he's huge but
he would at least be like he's huge he's
athletic yeah that would be a good fight
yeah if he starts eating now
maybe
maybe
also right now the whole internet's
talking about the fight and i feel like
that may be affecting a lot of our
answers like you're buzzing but you're
buzzing you're feeling
good a nice summer and you're like why
would i do that exactly yeah that's what
i think you think i feel the same way
like i i think
we had an awesome matchup and i don't
know necessarily what unless you were
like
felt totally like you wanted to rematch
i don't know what it would how different
it would be right right right so i would
rather b or bro
in creator clash two and then we both
have new enemies like but you know
cage match yo let's go you know my
stress i know yours and we just work
together
let's go
well if that doesn't happen i can i can
work on something just so free-for-all
for you guys
bring some some homeless people in keep
it classy
the parking lot yeah appreciate that
thing bum fights yeah remastered
20 20 so i will say
i was like very intimidated like i said
prior to the fight but one thing that
calmed me down is i saw a lot of
comments saying that you were the dan of
cow chop which our dan is the voice of
reason the producer who uh
takes care of all of us yeah so the
responsible one so i heard that i was
okay he looks scared but you know if
he's dan he's got a harder you might
feel a little bit better
best person i'm not like huffing glue in
my spare time being like gotta kill like
me
yeah yeah well there you have it guys it
was a great experience a wholesome
experience i mean all the fighters you
guys in particular
were incredible the a uh you know ian
and anissa did an amazing job pretty
cool man it was great to see
and thanks for stopping in it was so
nice to talk to you to be able to do
this together again
congratulations to both you guys what a
great event yeah and apparently the the
sales were good the attendance sold out
yeah yeah we're on the street
jake paul
oh his second yeah nobody watched that
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] awesome yeah you
beat his second pay-per-view event i saw
that too
thank you honda nice meeting you thanks
for coming dude take care oh you want to
plug something where where's people
check you out
what's muscle party
so here you wanna you wanna you don't
give it a plug thank you guys if you
wanna see more hyundai just go to
youtube.com muscleparty and then i
stream on muscle party too what is
muscle party what do you do on there uh
it's just kind of like it's like an
extension of like the couch chop stuff
or it's like sometimes it's worki but
it's like it's like funny stuff fitness
stuff it's like joke fitness comedy yeah
okay fitness comedy you could say that
the muscle party guys yeah when i s i
was like av gotta fight the muscle party
that sounds [ __ ]
bad thanks bro thanks for stopping in
that was great
uh hundar ladies and gentlemen of the
muscle party
we'd love to see it i'm gonna add the
link to his channel in the description
of the episode thank you thank you
wait apparently doctor disrespect is two
and wait doctor disregard six seven he's
six eight according to google and
we met him he was very tall but
extremely tall was he six eight i that's
that's his that's his tag line the six
foot eight great right right yeah yeah
six eight that's oh yeah he actually
he's taller than harley
i don't know if he'd agree to do it but
that that'd be a hell of a fight for
sure
people saying you and i should box ethan
ethan versus dan
this house divided cannot stand that's
right all right
he's gone now let's let's watch me let's
watch me get him on the ground real
quick
yeah i know but so so the one things i
wanted to say that i felt bad saying in
front of him was one
when he knocked you down it was clear
that you were off balance
that was clear yeah
and then two
the knock down you got him was a good
clean knockdown that was that was great
i was just you know i do think overall
to be totally partial
he impartial thank you dan he was he was
probably going to win
on a judgment but but but
the stats at the end of every round were
heavily in your favor like
he wasn't landing much because you had
the defense up and i think you had a
really good chance of winning on the
scoreboard i really thought so so that's
why i was shocked when they stopped it
yeah i i want to preface by saying yes i
think he would have won either way
especially the way he was unloading
those last two rounds but like my cousin
was showing me different like
screenshots of stats i'm like don't stop
sending me [ __ ] i don't want to see you
i was telling him why because you feel
bad i just yeah i just don't you want to
i'm happy with how it went yeah you
don't you don't want to want to like
feel regret well it could honestly you
both came out looking great so it was a
win-win to be honest
it really was
a lot of people asking you to ask abe
about his spray tan
oh yeah did you spray tan before the
fight right yeah i heard people couldn't
believe that people thought i was lying
so i got sunburned really bad if you
could see my chest right now
can't really tell it's peel it's peeling
oh yeah it was
i was really spotty and so eric from uh
common etiquette oh eric spray he
already got a spray tan then he sweated
it off
and so he was doing another one michael
briggs's uh girlfriend that came in kate
she does it and um
like why don't you come and we could
even you out and i was really hesitant
about it but she did a good job covering
me that'd be awesome if you just start
sweating the spray tan during the fight
so afraid well no i was afraid to pull
giuliani on on stage i was friends oh
yeah
yeah
and also i have this uh
blonde hair so i was showing them this
picture of you from that old h3 video
i'm like i'm really afraid i'm just
gonna look
just like borderline blackface
no it looked natural people didn't
believe me
um
anyway here is uh
the the knockdown i was joking with
honda that this is all we'll show with
no further context
damn
okay player
we were going crazy you have that clip
can someone's in the clip of us all
yeah i think that that's in the dark as
well
did you see it do you see did you see
those highlights from the oh yeah yeah
yeah here in the doc crew's reaction to
abe's knockdown right there
oh thank you
yeah here here this is from the members
stream we did
a little one on the chat
okay
yeah that was a great moment man it was
such a great fight because you guys went
back and forth you know the fact you got
that knockdown was what made it very it
made it good where you could come out
there feeling proud you know exactly
yeah yeah everyone told me i was going
to die so
to have just that you didn't die
you definitely didn't die
but yeah
but okay whatever you know you basically
begged the the ref to stop please i
can't do this yeah you say it once i got
my highlight once i got that that
knocked down i just want to get out
after that
yeah exactly just call it just forfeit
right after that
no vanilla seriousness i really wish we
got to finish but uh
i left happy
that's why the happiest have ever been
in my life
yeah i mean it's a lot there's a
well i mean the crap the audience looked
big but being there did it feel like
huge
it felt huge and i swear i felt like it
was all h3 fans yeah i've never been
that calm my life
watch the show knows that i still get
like shaky sometimes on here but i was
that night i was just
so calm i feel like it was just the i
felt the love all the love yeah it was
amazing shout out to the family we had
there was like 13 000 people just
watching our members only live stream so
if they sold a hundred thousand tickets
at least a quarter of it was h3 family i
would say it could be
you know should have got that damn
referral code dude you would have booked
and clean up but okay whatever
the shot
on the live stream we're all all family
all the time except for that one guy
spamming the unworth the entire event
oh their chat was full of family
we heard there was no moderation at all
people were just spamming the n word
it wasn't that there wasn't any at all
but they seemingly weren't banning
people so like people would like spam a
bunch of slurs and then those messages
would get deleted but then they would
just keep doing it and there was like no
bans being issued i was like ian of all
people
right
should know
that you're gonna need the moderation
but um well that's good that's nice to
know that it was all family in the chat
people we were spamming burritos
when you started fighting
someone had me sign a burrito
um
and i had the sharpie and i felt so bad
i ripped through the wrapping and got
his actual burrito well was he gonna eat
it it's a memorabilia i mean i think it
was just getting like a picture he needs
to uh suspend that in resin
yeah he's not going to eat it for
christ's sake that's that's valuable
well there you have it
the creator clash what a great event
good job baby thank you you brought
pride to our family
you didn't shame us thank you thank you
i was worried about it
lena how long i actually want to hear
from lina because she's
you were there the whole time and were
you stressing out well i was thinking
those fights were so brutal especially
like alex versus alex hearns versus ryan
mcgee yeah were you were you worried
watching that fight i was like the whole
time leading up to the fight i was just
stressing so much and then even at the
the actual fight too i was just right by
the ring and i was at the edge of my
seat the whole time and oh my god it
must have been stoned she surprised me
though because i thought she was gonna
be terrifying but when i was up there i
heard her go put your hands up oh really
screaming the camera didn't catch it but
after i knocked him down i looked at
lena i winked at her in the crowd so
wait you heard her saying put your hands
up yeah did you oblige was she right
dude he did he did it right after yeah i
saw there was a moment where hundard
told you to put your hands up i didn't
even
i mean i did when he said it so i must
have been in the moment like i said i do
not even remember that's interesting
uh avery uh mega awesomener just
messaged me this this is uh oh yeah i
guess i got yeah this was him uh signing
the burrito
it's not a real a b burrito though
because there's not like thumbtacks
inside
well we don't know there could have been
in there could have been anything
what oh what was a memorable moment for
you from the sidelines watching
um honestly the support from the h3 fans
they were screaming for him the whole
time really that's so cool it was really
cool and it did it really helped me feel
a little more comfortable too damn
family i got him down the whole house
like it was everyone was
dude that's sick
it was really cool well there you have
it
lena special recognition to you
for uh you know
going all through all that with ab
so
cheers
thank you very nice
very good
very nice and very good both
all right um we have some ads that we
need to do um
oh and i just realized
i don't have any uh music the way that
zach normally has oh no we need ad music
it's so awkward without music yeah
we used to do ads without music and it's
so [ __ ] awkward bro
let me do one without music so you guys
can see how awkward it is and while
you're doing that i'll cue up some and
then the second one burrito's in the
chat guys for a b come on throw up those
burritos what
oh we can just play something from the
page i want to do them without so you
guys can see how awkward it is okay
burrito's in chat ab you seen those
beautiful beautiful but these aren't
baby burritos because you can see it's
open face so it's not exactly right but
the sentiment is there yeah
we gotta sell we got if we do we got to
do a round of march where we got to put
your burrito on a shirt or something
that would sell well man people are
invested i think it would to be honest
yeah so many posters at the fight with
[ __ ] burritos
[Laughter]
that's crazy that the burrito meme has a
strong legs
such a powerful meme
that burrito is infamous
all from an ad read too
well speaking of ad reads our first up
is hello fresh oh what a coincidence
where the the
genesis of the burrito meme
comes from and there it is boy
there is that scrumptious burrito made
by abe god that looks good that burrito
has legs and what's inside of it well
let's take a look you gotta buy to find
out
nice grill marks wish i knew what was
inside of it
but you know what
it looks it looks good looks tasty and
you're gonna have to pay to find out
thank you to our wonderful sponsor
hellofresh
with hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
skip the trips to the grocery store and
count on health fresh to make home
cooking fun
easy and affordable
and that's why it's a number was num
america's number one meal kit as you'll
see
dan showcasing
these are all pictures from family
members
who have ordered
hello fresh and prepared it and boy
those dishes all look so good
and the thing about hellofresh
is they send it and pre-portioned fresh
product
they send an info card it tells you
exactly what to do
so if you're new to cooking or even an
expert
i personally i cook a lot and i learned
some some really useful tips on how to
cook my meats that i still use so i
learned a lot but if you're not good at
cooking they're gonna walk you through
it and uh it's home cooking man it's
good it's healthy it's fresh
what's interesting is
it's 72 percent cheaper than dining in a
restaurant
and it's even cheaper than going grocery
shopping
because apparently you know you don't
have to buy huge portions
they just send you the exact amount
so we love hellofresh
the family loves hellofresh go to
hellofresh.com h3tv 16 and use code
h3tv16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts thank you thank you that wasn't
that awkward
i like it better with music though
though the audience has been spamming
that is very awkward oh really awkward
awkward i hate it
all right well let's pump up that music
then
let's start pumping give it up for me
stop it for me uh mr give it up for mint
mobile let's drop that music hot
well it's no good if i can't hear it
it's just starting quiet it's there
is it not super quiet
i think it's just
i can't no i hear it it's just really
quiet well let me turn it up it's that
okay this is a bob
a louder dude come on i'm trying to do a
party dance
this song is [ __ ] sick
dirty ass beat bro
this is like dr is this what we call the
dr the drip step
okay mint mobile thank you
after years of fine print contracts and
getting ripped off by big wireless
providers
uh what did i say a street tv
no no
oh okay
after years of fine print getting ripped
off by big wireless providers if we
learned anything it's that there's
always a catch so when i first heard
that mint mobile offers premium wireless
starting at just 15 bucks a month i
thought
what's the catch
[Music]
but there isn't one
mint mobile secret sauce is that they're
the first company so wireless service
online only they're cutting out the cost
of retail stores and passing those sweet
savings onto you dan's been using mint
mobile
indeed
it's the same thing that's the secret
they use the same network it's just way
cheaper
that's right
same tech same uh
infrastructure same backbone same uh
same 5g same same great audio quality
great service same great audio quality
it you can send text messages people
you believe that i don't we have the
technology near 2022.
brand new uh for anyone who hates their
phone bill mint mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month
mobile gives you the best rate whether
you're buying for one or your whole
family and that mobile family started
just two lines all plans come with
unlimited talk and text plus high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network use your own phone with any
mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contacts switch to mit mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month so
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and to get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.comh3
that
oh
i see
uh mint mobile.com
h3tv
which you can see on the screen is the
correct url and in the in the
description that's mobile.com h3tv cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
mobile.com
h3tv thank you thank you
okay this one's a little i'm not it's
not giving me stamps but i like it
i keep it going keep it going
stamps.com
if you've got a small business and
you're feeling the strain
it's like elevator h3 kind of
you've been feeling the strain that
inflation is putting on all of us
right now it's harder than ever for
small businesses to stay profitable and
every dollar counts
that's why stamps.com is everything you
[ __ ] have
metal transition
[Music]
when he
okay thank you when you use stamps.com
to mail and ship you get access to a
clue exclusive discounts and great rates
on shipping so you can keep more money
in your pocket at the end of the day
here's the deal
saves you time money and stress for 20
years stamps.com has been indispensable
for 1 million businesses sams.com gives
you access to all the post office and
ups shipping services you need right
from your computer and it gets even
better discounts okay we're talking 30
percent off usps and 86 off ups what the
frick wow no matter the size of your
business stamps.com is ready to help you
save on shipping i'm talking invoices
etsy even a warehouse
uh stamps.com is your mailing and
shipping solution
plus stamps.com works seamlessly with
shopify amazon etsy ebay and more all
you need is a regular computer and
printer no special supplies or equipment
and you're up and running minutes
printing official postage for any letter
any package anywhere you want
send it so start mailing it
shippingwithstabs.com and keep more
money in your pocket sign up at sams.com
h3tv for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free posted and a
digital scale
no long-term commitment or contract
just go to stamps.com
h3 tv
[Music]
god that that song dropped so hard and
heavy
it's such a great one
i think that's the song i put at the end
of vape mage
oh is it yeah
wait are you ready
[Applause]
what happened i blocked out
i lost consciousness for a minute
i ascended
oh [ __ ]
you want to watch the michael reeves one
ab oh i didn't know if you just wanted
to keep going i was just sending this
went along dude michael reeves
oh my god that fight was crazy you know
they're both like 5'3 like short kings
right yeah
now michael reeves was
michael is a young man like 24 and then
his opponent graham reeves also a very
sweet guy graham stefan i'm sorry graham
graham reeves they got married
graham stefan was like uh
30 or something a little bit older
but michael's got that like
bro he's a little he's a little demon
bro
look at this
well
i'm seeing grams yeah graham is 30.
and michael's like 24.
[Applause]
he's a firecracker bro
yeah yeah
i think the reps about to call it
[Applause]
but you know what graham wow
warrior man he's a warrior getting that
ring
a few other guys and the whole time
anytime he wasn't doing maybe like
closer to your mic oh sorry
i've been away too long maybe yeah it's
been a while
but no he was like uh outside shadow
boxing every time he had a second shadow
really throwing a little ball catching
it yeah he has so much energy so uh it
was impressive
if only you could bottle that huh
yeah
god bless though
so
you know i'll just close my dock
oh no wait wait i think i can yeah i got
it
so all around what a what a yeah a great
time a good experience
um
so
let's move on i guess
how do you move on from such a powerful
topic but there it is
there it is um
since we're in between topics let me
just read off a couple
big fat donations we got in the first
half of the show somebody donated 100
bucks
hey ethan my mom started taking
wellbutrin going from lexapro i wanted
to send a thank you for talking about it
because she just swapped she's been much
happier and not as voracious nice what
is what what should happen is what
voracious voracious oh she's not eating
as much yeah thank you for being willing
to talk about this stuff on the podcast
that's awesome glad to hear you know i
just started my wellbutrin like three or
four days ago again because i had that
allergic reaction so far nothing okay
and i'm really
you noticed it i'm hoping well
they say it takes like you know like a
little six weeks before kicks in but
right so i'm just i was afraid of the
allergic reaction so so far it seems
like i'm fine by the way quick side note
emily baker is live with 116 000 people
watching holy [ __ ] have you noticed how
her
johnny depp coverage has been like
absolutely bonanza like trial of the
decade in it and she
has very good comments she
yeah she's got that perfect crossover of
like
pop and lawyer obviously a friend of the
show
uh total sweetheart but holy [ __ ] good
for her man
she found that niche bro that's crazy
116 000 okay h3 podcast who are you
how many we got like thirty six thousand
like what are we seven right now yeah
small time we're small beans compared to
emily baker
maybe she'll give us a shout out someday
yeah please let me just watch you wrote
the op-ed
last written statement that you
submitted in the uk action right
misheard correct and the statement was
made under oath
that is true boomerang directing your
attention to the last page of that there
you go yeah if you're gonna watch it you
might as well watch it with her
commentary you know
there it is uh oh xqc is 160 000 viewers
right now okay h3 podcast who are you
he's juicy asthma gold 140.
wait wait are you serious wait wait wait
that's one gold get that many well oh
they're watching the trial yeah yeah
we should be live streaming this [ __ ] i
didn't know this was such a views
bonanza i'd be [ __ ] talk about it
well creator clash johnny depp under
heard
let's talk about it let's watch it let's
turn it on and see if ever let's just
change the title to live stream and see
how many people we can get johnny depp
and amber heard versus dan johnny
johnny johnny yes papa eating sugar no
papa telling lies no papa open your
mouth ha ha
[Music]
i'm the only one with kids that was
great
oh sorry two kids ladies and gentlemen
two kids
[Laughter]
uh
wow the johnny depp thing is big news
okay shout out
it seems so dry to sit through a whole
court hearing like i'm sure there's
great moments in there but to watch like
a full
four hours of open court seems a bit
grueling doesn't it
but it's actually quite entertaining
i've been watching asmr gold a lot the
past
send me the link let's put it on let's
see
let's just [ __ ] let's try this out
i don't know let's go send me the link
bro let's see if our views go up
to that oh you're just mean to the trial
let's temporary change no no no let's
just watch asmr
no don't send me asthma gold send me the
link to the [ __ ]
i'm trying to get in on this
you weren't too specific i'm getting the
other thing
okay fair enough fair enough side
research okay so now temporary change
the um the title just save the title
that we have dan okay
copy paste that
and then let's temporary change the
title to uh
johnny depp versus amber heard live
or what's what's that's funny because
nobody's actually watching the stream it
only has one
it only has 1300 people watching
they're all watching emily
and asman what's emily uh
mega watching trial
let's just do
live
amber heard
what do you guys think johnny depp's
live reacting to amber herg versus uh
whatever his name is trial
johnny depp you forgot his name
yeah d johnny depp
surprise guest
comes to talk about
definitely live live all caps johnny
depp versus amber heard live again trial
live whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa
i get the feeling you're making a joke
out of this stan
um whoa some dude there's a there's a
channel law and crime that has seven
hundred and thirty thousand people
watching uh why whoa we're watching that
we're a news channel we're missing the
oj verdict right now yes okay wait
what's the long crime title love or cam
that's the one above i linked it
people are saying that the trial just
ended
are you serious well that's what they're
saying in the chat oh [ __ ] it's done
wreck oh we missed it
just pretend like we're watching it
still
yeah yeah they're just showing the clock
now did they go on
epic content yo watching the clock tick
y'all live
watching the passage of time live people
saying they claim don't show them
long crime following that content [ __ ]
so are they on a break or they just i
heard it ended for today oh guys okay so
are they back tomorrow because we gotta
hit that
we're not live tomorrow
[ __ ]
what about wednesday
are they going are they live on
wednesday love
yes yeah probably all right that's our
wednesday episode i want to hit that i
want to see let's make the event [ __ ]
full full throat bro let's go for it
that was such a complicated [ __ ]
i suited up and everything and they just
end the trial just like that well keep
it on keep it on a hanger
just keep it on for two days yeah you
can you can keep it on if it's easier
for you
um
[Laughter]
okay i'm excited for a wednesday
i'm not
well you better you better feign it
fake it till you make it dan
can't wait all right well that's this
domestic violence trial this is good
content
hey
when you put it like that it's kind of
sad yeah well that is what it is and
that's why i'm so annoyed
hey you can't help but like it's like
it's i agree spectator sports listen
like
it's odd it's weird
and i'm just here listen i'm just here i
just work here okay
you can't use that excuse me i just work
here you can't do it
oh jimmy lee's coming in on wednesday so
we can have him help comment at a
commentary no yeah cause zach called in
i would love to hear what jimmy lee has
to say see now it's interesting
absolutely now it's interesting oh maybe
you could tell us some like lawyer jokes
or something yeah jokes some or johnny
depp amber turd jokes domestic abuse
maybe he's got some wife beater jokes
yeah that he can tell tell him to
prepare okay maybe no
why no it's good
all right so zach called in sick so i
felt too bad because jimmy leaf flew out
here to l.a for just to do this thing
with zach
and um
by the way people have been sending
screenshots of him he's heckling people
he is in hollywood right now he is a
[ __ ] menace
people saying it's not a domestic
violence cases defamation case
defamation about what
what's the defamation about it's not a
criminal case they're right dan i didn't
say it was a criminal case but obviously
that is the subject matter that is being
covered
oh yeah so jimmy lee is already out in
l.a causing a muck
it looks like he's about to get decked
by this guy doesn't it
like that guy looks pissed dude
of course jimmy's got his bodyguard so
this is awesome so he's out there
already so i felt bad so i said once you
come in on wednesday and you can uh
you can test out your material
and we'll do a three strike system
if if they're too offensive we can we
can buzz them
and if he if he does three offensive
jokes if he hasn't learned his lesson
we're gonna
drag him off stage with a
comically oversized uh walking cane
like the old days
sounds fun
while watching amber heard and johnny
depp
we could just cut to it you know we'll
just cut to it so that we can yeah it's
going to be good
where else could you find this
you know what i mean
this is a place to watch it
this is the place
yo we got to get more celebrities
committing crimes man that [ __ ] is good
for business
what what would be a good crime for us
right now maybe like
let's say maybe a murder let's say if
trisha killed moses can i talk about it
then
like if one
all right fair enough
that would be good for views though
she's crying what what did i say wrong
huh
that it would be never mind let's move
on well it would
i mean
here's something a little more topical
uh what do you got what if jimmy lee
kidnapped jimmy kimmel today like the
king
a live hostage standoff yeah constant
situation
he's on hollywood boulevard right now so
i think it's very feasible he's coming
back for uh revenge i think that's i
think it's yeah i think that's a really
good hypothesis he's probably also
trying desperately to get
on the background against
you know jimmy still has that fantasy
like that you have when you're 12 years
old of like hey kid
you're like broke into a movie factory
and the producer's there hey kid you'd
be perfect for this spot
jimmy still thinks that's going to
happen with j with jimmy lee
um
someone said go back five minutes before
it ended it was insane
interesting
zach commented he said i've been
[ __ ] and puking my brains out you
know i'm right or die with jimmy
okay we believe you
totally believe you
so let me watch the end because
apparently it was nuts
wait so should i not watch in this long
crime one
how are they gonna claim me
i'm a bit confused by that comment it
might be true but that's the channel i
think everyone is watching um
i mean they can watch it that doesn't
mean that they're not getting claimed
okay so response to mr i heard that this
was not so let's watch it i don't know
if this is this the official statement i
really i have no idea
the same in that room practice for
wednesday action
amber heard that's the only thing i'm
going to say would you please read that
to yourself it's heard
she kind of looks like hillary clinton
like younger
yeah
a little bit yeah they do kind of
interesting right
can you turn up a little bit down
yes
okay
did you read all the way to the very
bottom where the last word is supported
this is [ __ ] thrilling riveting stuff
oh people are saying they claimed emily
baker
how are you gonna claim yes okay that's
the statement so
it's their coverage
it's their coverage so us usa today owns
this footage
yeah i mean these these trials
they allow the media in so oh my god
it's such a frenzy they're recording it
and it's their it's their footage
i mean we are commenting i think emily
probably is providing fair use
commentary too as a legal oh i'm sure
but yeah that's and i mean obviously i'm
no legal analyst but i have an
analytical mind
a beautiful mind some would say
released
through your spokeswoman after mr depp
made the donations to
the chla and the aclu correct miss herd
i do not recall exactly
what my statement was
i don't disagree with anything in the
statement but i just simply don't recall
what the statement was we were released
is there anything inaccurate in that
statement mr no okay i'm going to move
to admit objection you're on a lack of
foundation i'll overrule the objection
to one two six zero in evidence this is
[ __ ] great man how are our views
doing
yeah did the views go up or down
watching a rerun of the [ __ ] nothing oh
it's up we're up guys we're looking good
there's nothing worse than watching a
rerun of a court case bro that's the
worst
objection thank you your honor
like this isn't seinfeld let's be honest
amber is this the part you guys said
that was nuts
do i need to go further we're only going
by one five dollar comment or donation
so let me let me scream yeah let me go
forward
and had more publicity reach you wanted
to remind everyone of your claims of
domestic violence against mr depp right
no i wanted to move on with my life you
wanted to make those claims seem
believable
they are believable they wanted them to
be seen you wanted to be seen excuse me
as a noble victim of domestic violence
have never never wanted to be seen as a
victim
nor have i ever called myself one
you testified under oath that quote the
entirety of your divorce settlement was
donated to charity and quote didn't you
that's correct i pledged the entirety
no
misheard
my questions
your counsel will have time to redirect
you
after
you testified under oath okay quote this
is kind of juicy actually okay i'm
[ __ ] sucked in now
the entirety of your divorce settlement
was donated
to charity end quote that is correct i
pledged the entirety
i'm going to move to strike everything
after yes
all right
okay chill i mean you know it's a little
tech i mean
it's hard ass god help the judge after
this trial
be like yes that's i would strike
everything i have to guess
only yes can they do that
that's kind of interesting it's like i
only want yes in the record
miss hurt that's really inappropriate
i'll sustain the objection and we'll
just move forward let's move forward
next question okay
under oath that statement wasn't true
was it misheard
i'm sorry i don't follow your question
sorry oh please you know so the rumor or
i guess it's not even a rumor she
donated a small portion of her divorce
thing after she pledged to
give it all to charity right so that's
kind of a big uh interesting angle here
for
this is good you guys
probably wednesday is going to be all
this good dan
dan looks miserable
you're not interested this is good
i am not interested now
watch watch those numbers dan looks so
sad right now
i'm just i'm you know we're over 40 000
dan you better be getting i try to
change the title so it doesn't have
anything to do with that are you sure
well i didn't change the title to be
anything related to the trial
but we're watching it i guess so
you testified under oath quote the
entirety of my divorce settlement was
donated to charity end quote that
statement wasn't true
it is true i pledged the entirety to
charity
the statement when you say you buy a
house you don't pay for the entire house
next question it's a bad analogy you're
not buying a house you have money you're
giving it
with the house you're buying something
and you may not have the all of the
money to buy it
so you need extra money
but if you're giving money away you
don't need extra money you just give the
money away
you could say i pledge it doesn't mean i
gave it
statement is technically true because
she pledged it
please thank you
that statement isn't true today as you
sit here today is it
it is true i pledged the entirety please
you didn't donate it's a yes or no i
haven't been able to obligate i mean to
fulfill those so that's the no right
i am i made the pledge i want to be very
clear i pledge the entirety i haven't
been able to fulfill those pledges
because i've been sued you had all of
the seven million dollars
for 13 months before mr debt sued you
and you chose not to pay it to the
charities you pledged it too
correct i disagree with your
characterization of that
let's look at your sworn testimony from
the uk
damn
dude i kind of look like the messiah if
you look at the court all right yes
ma'am
kind of everyday jesus
thank you
views are going up damn we're at 41 000
but they just keep rising yo what the
[ __ ] bro what have i been talking about
anything but johnny dip and i feel so
stupid for missing this
oh my god dude
wednesday's going to be gangbusters
watch it's fast cause do you want me to
close the shades
just there's this light coming across
them so i appreciate that it's probably
a good light
thank you your honor all right
i don't have to talk i just sit here and
watch the show
but still analyzing you know it's
important to say that
i pause and i analyze that was a
humorous remark i'm thinking when i get
deposed later they'll be like why did
you say that
no that's a joke i'm pausing and
analyzing
usda today sues me
for copyright infringement
okay that lady's got a third witness
statement that you submitted in the uk
action right miss
correct and this statement was made
under oath true that is true i'm
directing your attention to the last
page
of that statement
that's your signature right
yes it is so you made the sworn
statement on february 26 2000
2020. dan i got the views keep going up
dan you can't deny it
that's cool i'm so interested on how why
this is happening because yeah he didn't
change i didn't the [ __ ] change the
title yeah dude they just keep it's in
the title it's in the back end but they
just keep in the title they just keep
trickling in bro
everybody's saying that i need to stop
being mad i'm not mad
it's am i just am i allowed to not care
about this
like i just i don't have any interest in
johnny depp amber heard i think it's
weird that everybody is obsessed with it
but this part is is kind of fascinating
i'm hooked right now all right and
directing your attention to paragraph
four
she giving me sith lord in that outfit
quote i remained financially independent
from him the whole time we were together
and the entire amount of my divorce
settlement was donated to charity end
quote that is correct that's not true
correctly yes you did
the hymn you were referring to is mr
duff
that is correct
it says mr death in the
the auto caption
most of the money that was donated to
the aclu and chla in your name came from
someone else isn't that right
i don't know what you mean by most of
well at least five hundred thousand
dollars that was donated to the aclu in
your name wasn't paid by you right
uh i believe elon made a donation in my
honor on one one of the years
elon musk is involved in this [ __ ] and
she date him or something at one point
but they broke up and then he's donating
on her behalf like what in the [ __ ] i
haven't listened too much recently but i
know in the beginning of the trial her
attorney said that uh johnny depp is
obsessed with elon musk and we'll hear
more about that later on as his trial oh
did they get to that yet i don't know if
i missed that i was totally
tuned out last week let me check
in like a weird way that like he got
cucked by elon or
or like just he loves elon as a dude
because a lot of people like elon is a
dude
i i think she's implying that he got
jealous of their relationship but i'm
not sure i'm just speculating joe you
got elon musk involved in this dan this
is intriguing this is high drama this is
this is riveting stuff
and it didn't come out of your seven
million dollar divorce it's almost like
a joke like the views keep going up and
it's almost just like a joke like i
don't know where these people are coming
and they're in on the joke and they just
keep coming in but it's crazy guys it's
pretty wild
no nor did it count towards my pledge
and at least 500 000 that was donated to
the children's hospital of los angeles
and your name wasn't paid by you either
right those were made at the same time
so that didn't come out of your 7
million divorce settlement nor did it
count to my
3.5 obligation those 500 000 payments
came from your new boyfriend elon musk
right
he i don't know if he was a new
boyfriend at the time
he's an old standard
elon musk is putting out nice fat
donations for her
hey baby i just want to let you know
that's what you do when you're trying to
get those panties wet when you're a
billionaire you're like hey baby
i just gave half a million dollars to
the aclu
what you doing tonight
that's [ __ ] dope
what's even crazier if she claimed that
she donated that and then never gave any
that's [ __ ] epic
you got him to pay part of what you
promised to these two charities didn't
you incorrect
because you wanted to keep at least some
of the seven million divorce settlement
for yourself right i'm very wrong about
that
i think this
if you're honored okay you said this is
a good breaking point okay that's fine
all right ladies and gentlemen we'll
stop here for the evening remember
tonight do not do any outside research
and not discuss the case with anybody i
know these days are a little long
interesting man i just want to go back
and keep watching i mean as long as the
views are going i'm about 42 000 down i
mean let's just go set it up at the
beginning go for it yeah that's what i'm
saying boom over here
i think i should just be on dan the
whole time when we watched his face
i just cut the dan from now on in
i guess well we have a whole plan but
you guys just want me to watch this the
plan isn't very good
yeah [ __ ] the plan you got to throw the
plan out the window we're going to talk
about fresh and fit spending 14 hours uh
oh yeah yeah five minute conversation
who gives a [ __ ] right we had that
okay do a poll do a poll continue
watching johnny depp
because
continue watching johnny depp or do the
regular app
let's touch johnny yes papa
i'll put that yeah here
while you guys look
um well you guys vote
there you go it's going up right now
yeah and while you guys vote let's just
put on a banger a billion views on this
who's ready for
johnny yeah this is going to get me
claimed
yeah this will get explained
for the poll we should say leave it on
johnny yes
or no papa
do the original plan okay dan the people
are with you
but unfortunately a lot of people are
watching so actually if you guys could
vote
for the depth trial i'm
i'm kind of i'm gaming over here so yeah
he's an intense game of doom right now
yeah you're playing doom doom simulator
yeah
well i'd like you to be present
you know even if it's johnny yes papa i
i have to pay attention
yes you need to watch every second i
need your announcement i feel like i can
do both
well anyway we're not we're gonna move
on but i'll tell you what on wednesday
we definitely [ __ ] rollin
yes baby
yes yes yes well now since we're on the
topic was there any other good moments
from there was one where she denies
pooping in the bed
as you know this is the most
hotly uh uh debated
moment of the trial
and then on the other side
dan is playing
uh doom
now why do i have to watch you play doom
dan cause you just put that on the
screen i don't know if you guys can see
but now i gotta watch dan play doom
this is a really cool simulator dan was
telling me that they
it's basically the original doom but
they amped it up so that it's like more
graphic right is that that's part of it
it's like a modern fps all right right
right how is that modern it looks like
the same oh because the other one moved
like this i can look up and down oh you
couldn't look up and down in the
original there's like way more gore
okay it's [ __ ] sick look at that dude
all right we're gonna get demonetized
for video game gore or can they not see
it
are you showing idiom
all right take it off this is too
graphic come on look at this new graphic
turn it off
turn it off
look at this stop turn it off
all right let's watch this
dan start a gaming channel what do you
want from me
what if anything did you notice uh about
any bathroom issues in your bathroom
issues
[Music]
she [ __ ] the bed
you left for coachella
well
raquel and i were both in in that bed um
with the dogs and i didn't notice
anything but we left them in the bed
while we packed a bag
to go to coachella you know so that
turn it off
so that boo particularly didn't lose
control for about or you know didn't go
to the bathroom on the floor so we'd
leave him in bed until you're ready to
take them outside to the patio which is
their designated bathroom break area
and what if any people asking it's
called brutal doom just google brutal
doom guys i'm trying to do a show here
everybody's interested in what mod i was
playing it's called brutal doom just
google it there's instructions on how to
play it
unbelievable
we're there how often did you have
housekeeping keeping at that time at
your house keep cranking from the
housekeepers were there every morning or
they came every day
though i i guys i know you want me to
move on but i need to know
what happened with the grumpy
who laid who who laid the grumpy yeah
okay
now
we'll get you to coachella but
why did you tell starling jenkins
that you had been involved in a prank
gone wrong objection hearsay leading
i've said why your honor i didn't say
what she said i'll sustain the objection
next question okay um
did you commit any kind of prank
absolutely not
okay absolutely not and and why
would
that not be something you would do
first of all i don't think that's funny
i don't know what
grown woman
does i i
was not also in a pranking mood i had my
life was falling apart
maybe you were [ __ ] in bed mood
it doesn't sound like no prank that
sounds like an angry grumpy
at a crossroads in my life it was really
serious and i had just been attacked on
my 30th birthday
by my violent husband with whom i was
desperately in love
and knew i needed to leave
it was a not really a jovial time
and i don't listen lady did you [ __ ] the
bed or not
you know what i mean
the lady asked you a pointed question
okay
write a book
if you want to talk about other stuff
did you [ __ ] the bed i don't think
that's funny period that's disgusting
and what if any uh understanding did you
have of mr depp coming back to your
bedroom that night or the next morning
objection culture speculation i i'm
asking what are understanding what i'll
sustain the objection okay did you
had you had any conversations with mr
depp about him coming back to the house
the next day
no johnny didn't come back to that house
that was my
that was my
you know he owned it but that was my
house when when we were having any sort
of problem in fact that was my house
just 90 percent of the time because he
just didn't
come back
that was not a place that johnny was
going to be in that johnny was in and he
had stormed out on my birthday and as
per what we did it was he would go and
stay at his west hollywood home and i
would stay at the downtown places
he wasn't going to come back
so she she's denying laying the grumpy
but let's be fair
who would who would confess to [ __ ]
in the bed
you know
who among us
um
she did explain a little bit more
at some point in the trial and she said
that
there was this dog i think her friend's
dog who had eaten weed that apparently
johnny depp
had left open
like on the counter she said that their
dog consumed weed johnny's weed when the
dog was younger and that's why the dog
has had bowel problems since that sounds
like [ __ ] bro how's we gonna [ __ ] up
his bowel system for life
for life
sounds like a tall tale and by the way
um like we said that's that dog is so
tiny they have a tea cup
by the way how the [ __ ] is who [ __ ] in
the bed even material to this case
you know what i mean like how did how is
that even material it's interesting
no it's it's not a yorkshire i thought
it was a teacup
uh the article that i read about it said
terrier
okay because shredder's a terrier and
shredder could leave a [ __ ] like that in
the bed
but johnny was saying they have a teacup
and these things are like five pounds i
mean there are tiny tiny little critters
and look at that cute little thing oh my
god you think that thing's leaving a
chit in the bed oh no
look at that thing bro oh my god stop it
stop it how dare she to fame the dog the
dog needs to sue her
all right there you go
dd mega doo doo
um there you have it uh
heard claimed that their dog boo has
lifelong bowel control issues that's
inappropriate
all right let's move on thank you guys i
gotta do the dog like that
all right get ready for wednesday
everybody tune in
should we wear suits or something like
make it a whole ordeal
maybe we could get signs yeah
justice for johnny justice for johnny we
should come i bet they have justice for
johnny merch because i don't i don't
want any of those weird comments
you know the last time we talked about
it first of all i have never gone johnny
i have never gone after johnny okay
ever
but even still
without like absolutely cursing amber's
existence
there was like so many clone comments on
the last episode you saw it right then
oh yeah
people leaving the exact same comment
that was like or like slightly different
wording but like it was a little clearly
like a copy
pasta a little suspicious right yeah it
was weird and they all had like too many
up votes and too much yeah and they were
all like listen if you're not even gonna
take the time to learn the facts then
you shouldn't even talk about this case
uh amber heard is a liar and blah blah
blah it felt a little
fishy
a little bit
like
conspiracy theory
what do we make fun of johnny for just
that he said grumpy i mean no he had
this video where he was uh i think it
was in relation to this situation
actually but it was a long time it was
over a year ago where he was like in a
cave thanking his fans like it looked
like he was a vampire in a cave it
looked like he was in a cave or a
dungeon thanking his fans for the
support and there's like a candle it was
very uh wait pull it up
wait people got mad at us what am i not
allowed to make fun of poor johnny depp
i can't even [ __ ] goof on the guy for
an old funny clip who gets this revenant
who even gets this uh
this level of uh
revenant revenants
reverence reverence thank you like damn
the queen don't even get that respect
right so [ __ ] dude what the [ __ ] is this
okay wait what is this clip i don't even
remember this from 2020
oh my god our set looked horrible back
then
hang on
just send me the original clip i don't
know
i'm looking for it it's tough to find
anything original with all the johnny
depp stuff right now okay here i'll just
watch it then it's a nice little
flashback johnny did his instagram video
the countdown it's just too meta for me
guys
let me just watch okay
i think yeah i feel like johnny depp
really lost it when he started to really
think he was captain jack yeah because
like he started he started i remember
this now
it's my audience hi he's in a dungeon or
what where is he
feels like a vampire quality
right
he's is he farming
what do you call the bat [ __ ] guano is
he farming guano or some [ __ ] thank you
yes i feel like it's it's just too meta
if you guys can't find the original
but
the uh
yeah that highlight
has uh read some choice ones seventeen
hundred upvotes to three thousand oh my
god goodness dude yeah
wait what let me read some comments way
to go man let's just kick the guy even
more while he's down wait
what was the context of
was he already getting cancelled and
stuff yeah yeah it was probably around
the time that the uk trial was going on
where he sued the sun
for libel for calling him a wife beater
johnny is actually going through it i
don't think it's in your best interest
to make fun of him don't thumbs in my
best interest
make fun of everybody
the man's in a cave
he's got he thinks he's in like a
[ __ ] frankenstein film
the irony of making fun of celebrity
having an out of touch moment is strong
i like many here dude these people
they're so
what is this johnny depp simping it's
nuts
um
you could still goof on him for doing
something silly no and he can also be a
victim of amber heard's harassment
like you know
damn bud
damn boy
i'ma get killed for even saying this
watch in the comments
uh
the irony of making fun of celebrity
i like many other people who are hd fans
but this is just bullying
you definitely you do not watch the show
or poor johnny johnny depp is not gonna
[ __ ] explain the world
you're getting bullied
what the [ __ ] are you saying i know
what the [ __ ] he didn't do anything to
you what
what
what this is crazy logic like johnny's
got to come spit in my face otherwise i
can't ever make fun of him for doing a
[ __ ] like are you afraid of the dark
moment where he thanks his fans from a
damn
cave it looks like he's on the pirates
of the caribbean ride
he didn't do anything to you why make
fun of him for everyone to see are you
12
it's not even like he said something
controversial you're just making fun of
who he is and trying to get everyone to
mock him you don't need content like
this it's mean-spirited
bro
sorry but he's not a [ __ ] he's the
epitome of cool you just don't get it
that is funny
i mean listen all
oh
love to johnny but he's one of the
biggest stars in the world i'm pretty
sure he's fair game for some for some
light ribbing
part of his instagram people like yeah i
wish i could find the original video now
i'm going to drag him into a coffin
all right good night oh you did okay
let's watch it all right let's see can i
is it even possible for me to bully
johnny depp
here it is you guys tell
me uh let's take a walk through memory
lane i'm gonna get creamed in the
comments for this guys
get ready
you got the countdown it's a little
dramatic guys it's a little melodramatic
i don't they probably added that in his
defense whoever made this
right there hi
hi
everyone hello to
whoever might be out there in youth land
receiving this transit mission
um
concerning my first experience within
the world of social media
i've never heard oh okay this was his
first ever instagram post dude this is
[ __ ] hilarious like like this is just
the oddest content you could ever put on
instagram you know
this is [ __ ] fascinating come on now
done any of this before
um
i don't think i've really ever
felt any particular reason to until now
um
yeah now is the time
to open up a dialogue did he ever post
again
i was i was just looking let me see
you give it it's giving me uh
garth brooks i say let the conversation
begin yeah garth brooks
all right posting more he did post more
okay there you go all right i'll leave
poor johnny alone
we love johnny depp
you know there's he's amazing he's the
coolest man that ever lived
10 number 10 million views on instagram
that video
yeah there was that was his countdown i
was wrong that is his countdown yeah he
added that [ __ ] straight in there bro
yeah that's how you do instagram posts
as you well know countdown from 10.
it's funny all right let's move on uh
enough thank you please don't kill me be
nice i'm just [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
uh don't murder me my family okay thank
you
don't do a bomb don't please don't send
a bomb to my house because i [ __ ]
made fun of johnny depp
okay
all right so fresh and fit
as you guys remember we had a very brave
young girl
call into our show on what day was that
last week
last to wednesday
last wednesday
uh she
shared this horrible
night that she had with the fresh and
fit specifically fit
um
have you talked to her sam freshman fit
did a six hour
response stream
and
look i'm just gonna say it straight bro
like
i'm not [ __ ] watching the six-hour
stream no nobody wants i know and i
wouldn't even subject any of you guys to
watch that i appreciate that i mean six
hours
to me
now but i think from what i've the
snippets that i've got it's basically
exactly what i predicted
where it's like she was texting me she
was nice she wanted to hang out she came
over to my apartment it's like bro none
of that [ __ ] changes this anything
uh sam have you talked to her is she
doing okay yeah i have um i've stayed in
contact with her she's fine um she's
getting some hate you know to be
expected from their
fans but other than that i think she's
she's doing okay i mean i it doesn't
seem like anything they said would
convince anyone other than
people that are already
so far gone
down the black
these people are like black build bro
you know what say here's one moment that
did stand out to me that i thought was
pretty funny they had the cap counter
for every time they got her
uh what did it what did it finish at
like 120 or something
i don't i'm not kidding it wasn't it was
yeah it was that obscene
what do you guys think about this moment
though
oh [ __ ]
i'm excited to do these types of shows
because guess what this has happened to
me before girls come out with crazy
alligator how many times does this
happen to you
like i'm just curious it's never
happened to me once i'm right yeah i'm
the same age as fit i think right about
and uh i have never been accused of
doing it i'm just saying like like if
it's happening to you so many times
once
like okay maybe
maybe i can believe you
twice
three times plus
[Music]
i think
i might trust the ladies
at three plus
i trust one girl trust me but i think he
just snitched on himself big time
there's other accusers out there you
guys he just said they're what the [ __ ]
dude you're dumb you're a [ __ ] idiot
but to me before girls come out with
crazy allegations and what do i have i
have the proof you got me
blah blah blah all this other [ __ ] you
coursed me in a sex really define
coercion so he just said that some girl
accused him of coursing him into sex
he literally just said that like
that's disgusting bro
but you know
that's kind of what the the red pill
dating
culture is
it's like a playbook of how to coerce
women into having sex with you
so for him he's like yeah that's my
strategy that's
literally that's literally my objective
yeah um so i guess to him it doesn't
sound that offensive
why would you want to have sex with an
unwilling participant
you know uh
dude
don't you want to have sex with somebody
that wants to be with you
uh that's just a stretch perhaps but uh
yeah
well the definition to me is hold on
stop the show
stupid no don't do record scratches when
you're talking about
siri rod stop somebody take that record
scratch away from me then there's a
takashi 69 soundbite that followed it
stupid yeah
class it's not what the definition to
you what is the webster [ __ ]
dictionary oh well i don't define it
that way this is the crazy club world
where
what's the
what's the webster dictionary
what what is he asking us to define
what is it what essay or or
coercion okay
okay yo
do you even know what coercion means
just yeah you had sex with me
begrudgingly okay
i didn't coerce you
wild okay
you're guilty until proven innocent you
must protect yourself and keep receipts
don't listen to ethan don't listen to
any of these weirdos that are telling
you oh well you just have a guilty
conscience oh so i'm just supposed to
bro the biggest proof that he has a
guilty conscience that he did a six-hour
[ __ ] podcast with 120 caps like if he
was really innocent it would be so easy
to explain
if he really could prove but like if
you're gonna talk for six [ __ ] hours
about she talked about in 30 minutes
that is
over compensating big time dude
how many accusers do you have fit
i think you need to say how many
accusers you have
and then i'll judge then i'll then i'll
take it from there
also i mean i understand you know i i
get why he's reacting this way um
but
i think it is important to point out the
girl that called in because i i don't
know if we have a clip of this but they
kept saying that she's a cloud chaser
the girl that called in called in
anonymously she wanted never showed her
face never showed her face didn't say
her name the only people who know who
she is are people that went down a
rabbit hole and purposely sought her out
so she's not
seeking clout and she also
you can disagree with her
characterization she did not accuse them
of sexual assault she was actually went
out of her way whatever way to say
that's specifically not characterized as
essay now if people are reading between
the lines and that's what they're taking
from her story that's that's fine but
she
she is not she did not make that
specific accusation
she called in to tell her story because
she had
an uncomfortable time with him and
because he's a [ __ ] loser and wanted
to make fun of him and reveal what a
weirdo he is and how little gamey and
like the tim poole
comment and just
all of that
um
and even you know even if we just set
anything you know they're panicking
because they think they're being accused
of doing something or trying to like
unorganize like an effort to cancel them
or something right but let's just for
argument's sake just set aside like just
say okay nothing illegal happened she
was of age and there was and you know
nothing untoward in that way happened
it's
still her story still demonstrated i
mean this is a guy who makes a living
being this alpha male
red pilled dating advice guy
and he's a [ __ ] loser he's got no
[ __ ] game like a little loser
no game nobody even wants to she just
couldn't she wanted to get out he's
admittedly never had a girlfriend yeah
this man is a [ __ ] loser mid 30s and
the only time he gets sex he just admit
himself is coercion in fact he's been
accused of causing women to sleeping
with them
he has several accusers
uh and we just extracted this from a 40
39 seconds
of a six hour [ __ ] stream well i
think we should react to the full six
hours at the same rate johnny that they
reacted so we we talked to her for like
45 minutes and that was six hours so we
need to do like a 36 hour marathon no no
more it's like 120 hours
but uh
yeah it's it's almost so risky
the girls and i would think that ethan
of all people would
double check his facts before bringing
someone on to just okay i would think of
all people that you wouldn't [ __ ]
even talk right now because literally
your mind's in coconuts and barbados you
think it's wednesday it's actually
monday dude
we vetted her i think we were really
responsible we vetted her very well
before we brought it on we proved that
she was there we saw some tech they're
not even denying that they know that she
was there and that they had this
interaction sam what was your vetting
process like with her
well i just asked her to send me any
proof all proof that she had that she
was there she even i don't know if i
even put it in the dock but she sent me
pictures of her like in the studio
like
i don't know i don't know i mean all we
needed to know is that she was there her
story is her story yeah what am i
supposed to vet how am i supposed to vet
her
first person account prove whether or
not what you know her story you didn't
put her in a polygraph you didn't lie
detect her first it's like
you know
that's just [ __ ] too
so i mean fresh
with peace and love
even your own friends say you're dumb
that's not even my words that's just
i didn't even say you're dumb your own
fred said that so i'm quoting them
spread lies bro i mean
how am i spreading a lot so there you go
um
she's trying desperately again he
doesn't even he doesn't even deny trying
to sleep with her
now again he's like 39
and she's not quite that old but
35 i think he's like 35.
this is ages 30 to 35.
he's 35 she said and he's 19. yeah
oh he's 30 yeah i'm 30 to 36.
yeah and again you know she's 19 she's
of age that's not illegal he also said
it was it's just you're a [ __ ] loser
if you're trying to hit on 19 year olds
when you're in your mid 30s i'm sorry
you just are and also he he there was a
moment where he talks about he knew they
were he's like i didn't give them
alcohol they were drinking on their own
in the studio that i own
that i control he's like they're 19 year
olds and they pick the alcohol himself
hello bro that's your [ __ ] studio you
knew they were drinking and you knew she
was 19.
and then you took her back and then
later you [ __ ] take her back to your
place you're 35
she's 19. you are a [ __ ] loser bro
there's so many great moments that came
out of this actually
um
slams ethan and crew for wearing max
and caring about being vaccinated
okay massive dub let's see
unlike you we bring people on the show
right that are not media trained okay
you're more concerned about people
wearing max masks and being backs and
everything else like that which is why
when we challenge you so we'll go over
there and you ask us it's literally the
law
and i'm i'm very curious to see what
they say about that like like i'm not
[ __ ] doing that for my pleasure it's
the [ __ ] law it was at like the
height of the pandemic i was like are
you vaccinated you're coming into a
small studio space and shouting and
breathing potentially a couple feet away
from me i have two young kids
are you vaccinated and they were dodging
the question um bro you're [ __ ]
mental you want to come give me covenant
and potentially infect my children well
they didn't dodge the question they said
yes we're both vaccinated oh they lied
well i'm curious to see what he has to
say right now because i feel like the
truth is going to come out well then
they said yes and we said let's see your
background cards they said we can't
share that with you it has it has
personal id we said block out the
personal information then it's fine just
send it with whatever you're
uncomfortable sharing with us blacked
out
never mind we're okay with doing it over
zoom yeah that was what that's the exact
order of it by the way you know how dumb
these guys are those cards are meant to
be shared publicly it's literally for
showing publicly you [ __ ] [ __ ] like
you guys are literally operating
on the lowest iq possible
you said we'll go over there and you ask
us all these questions about
vaccinations or whatever all these
questions are you vaccinated that's the
one question how many questions could
you ask
it's a yes or no question like us we
bring people on they're not necessarily
media trained which means they don't
understand the concept of one mic at a
time they don't understand that you need
to be one fist away from a short sm7b
they don't know this stuff
on this show so we have to give them
rules and parameters prior to the show
so they don't hurt the quality of the
show
okay but you don't know that because you
don't let anyone into your studio
because you're so scared of you know
the virus the virus oh my god
it's insane
they're like dude you didn't want us to
come into your studio break la city law
and potentially give you coved to spread
to your children you're [ __ ] scared
of the virus bro
but
we were okay with them coming in the
studio we just asked if they were
vaccinated very simple
we ask a lot of people that and there's
never really a problem only time it's
ever been a problem yeah no it's super
simple literally the only time it's ever
been a problem they act like we have
these huge like
goal posts
uh bro literally nope just vaccination
good okay so let's continue on here
and just so you guys know these guys
used to wear masks in the studio when
they were used to do this pod so i think
now that i think they finally took their
masks off
okay and they're doing it we did it like
a week when we had a covet scare yeah
somebody
so funny man
it's just funny that that's like the
dunk that they have is that we're safe
about covet and care about having a safe
working environment for
our
ourselves which is amazing so let's
continue on
it is amazing
so you know they hitting hard
obviously coming for the jugular
um
here's the alcohol moment
so good
pressure boys encourage all the girls to
drink before and during the podcast
that's interesting she was 19. oh that
we're gonna have was threes this is cab
number three uh
so we have people that were there the
same night right yeah now we're in the
same environment it's everything so
when coconuts start going bro you gotta
cut his mic off because you know he's
about to incriminate you guys
this man let him never take the stand or
be deposed
you guys are gonna fall hard cap number
three uh he talks about how his guests
aren't media trained coconuts ain't
media trained
so we have people that were there the
same night right yeah that were in the
same environment it's everything so
ladies can you tell us what happened
that night when you were here
uh
okay
well that girl i guess specifically
only drink water
uh
i i mean good choice because you're
underage
so go ahead hit that play that thing
real quick chris
yep
by the way didn't her own story she said
she did that's a video of her
having a drink with them got it 19 year
old caller with alcohol there she is
monday holding a white claw you are
drinking with the underage girl
huh in your studio
and this was three minutes later after
they said that she only drank water yeah
which she said she only drank water at
the show
out here so they're they're the those
two all right
or is that the girl on the left so can
you tell us what happened that night
that was her that was her with the
blurred face got it they blurred her
face the whole time
which to be fair was
i mean it's good they did that i wonder
what because i
oh you blurted okay good so that that
seemed like too gracious on their part
oh that was nice of you ian that's good
that's very good
yeah of course they'll accuse her of
clout chasing when as we've talked about
time and time again
accusers never get clout they get
negative attention only like there's
literally nothing to gain from being an
accuser ever never has there been one
person that gained from being an accuser
if you could point one out i'd love to
see it like genuinely
i was actually the one that handed i
asked them
what they wanted and they said that they
wanted white claw and so then i asked
them what flavor they wanted
and i was the one that was like going
through the cans picking the flavor that
they wanted oh so wait she said the
flavor she even wanted too yeah
yeah in your studio a 19 year old is
drinking alcohol
you [ __ ] morons you guys are dumber
than the than a [ __ ] rock i mean how
dumb you guys
literally just confessed to a crime so
did they roll back the cap counter
we gotta roll back there we gotta roll
back the countdown because we called cap
on that and that raised it up to three
caps but now i see that you are openly
talking about the fact that she was
drinking roll it back roll you gotta
subtract one cap but these these
gentlemen just uh can
confess to committing a crime
you know they made a big deal about
having witnesses on and [ __ ] i mean what
the [ __ ]
so dumb
too dumb to live
uh
but
oh and then rollo tony browntown friend
of the show of course
rolo tony brown he's so embarrassing you
know
he kept uh
he kept leaving comments during the live
uh the rational mail of course you know
there's a lawsuit now
burn these guys or they keep coming back
lawsuit now
now rollo tony browntown i myself am
somewhat of a legal uh
how do you say it's how would you say i
i might uh
what's the good verbiage well let's just
say this isn't my first rodeo
where's zach when you need him this
wasn't my first road yeah i'll just i'll
just audibly do this
yeah
so this isn't my first rodeo i can do
the coconuts and barbados one pretty
cool
all right you can contribute with that
go into barbados
yeah um dude go ahead and sue me get in
line and uh when you're done
literally sue for what what are we what
are we talking about here i'm assuming
defamation okay
well that's literally bro it's the
dumbest that's not well that works an
anti-slap that [ __ ] so fast and you'll
be paying for my attorney's fees and
trust me bro like i said get in line you
know there's a billionaire suing me four
times and i don't [ __ ] blink at that
so why am i scared of you morons i think
even coconuts is smart enough to know
that's an l but the rational male of
course irrational male more like it
wants them
how about the how about the
girlfriend-less male because these guys
apparently don't [ __ ] get dates
because they're such losers burn these
guys to the ground or they keep coming
back go ahead and burn me [ __ ] burn
them to the ground crush your enemy
utterly leave no one to come back to
oppose you dude aren't you the guy
sitting there in sleeveless tank tops
you're like 50 years old and you have
hair down to your ass
what the [ __ ] are you to acting tough
about crush your enemy dude
okay genghis khan you [ __ ] have a
youtube channel with like 20 sub 20k
subs like chill
can you imagine someone actually talking
like that he's 50.
law 15 crush your enemy total apparently
it's a reference to some book of power
this dude thinks he's machiavelli or
something
no dude that's who you are
you literally sitting next to a [ __ ]
fax machine
[Laughter]
dude the only thing you're crushing is
bedtime at 8pm
i'm just saying dude
you know look how many pens he's got in
that pen holder bro you ain't crushing
the [ __ ]
whoa
that is that's too many pens the only
thing you're crushing is what are you
writing i'm just saying that's like an
old man's office no i get it what is
what has he got to write
you got like 80 pence shoved he's
writing letters he literally likes
reddish people
yeah roll up tony browntown you're such
a [ __ ] loser
like i'm sorry bro but please you dress
like you're 15
uh what is the picture of him as like in
rockstar mode uh guitar
i think he's actually 50. how old is he
rolo tony yeah he's i believe he's in
his 50s he might even be over 50.
[ __ ] cool no please just chill the f
please
dude you have a chin strap what the [ __ ]
you literally have a chin strap bro
don't talk about crusher you are not
allowed to talk about masculinity if you
have this on your [ __ ] face yeah
period full stop that looks like baby
stubble
like what the [ __ ]
like uh why would you
like it's literally he's literally a
neck beard like he's like purposely only
shaved it's a necklace his face
yeah that is
that's weird press your enemy total
lawsuit or they keep coming back he says
h3 has money
attorneys will take this case
rollo tony browntown is under the
impression that defamation lawyers take
pro bono cases
um that might be actually i still wonder
about matt hoss of his attorney
but the problem is um roller tony
browntown i'll explain it because
obviously you don't understand it
when you lose that which you will to an
anti-slap you're going to have to pay
for my attorney fees so it's not just
like a no lose proposition for
you and like you said i have money
you're right about that and my lawyers
are very good
so cap counter 71 oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] so in summary these guys are
clowns they didn't prove anything is
basically exactly like i expected which
is enough for his fans obviously
but the girl i had a really slam dunk
argument in like hour five but nobody if
they had if they had were like yo here's
a camera in my
uh here's a camera in my apartment and
you can see the whole time nothing
happened or here's a text message of her
saying i lied about this or whatever
something insane like that they would
have showed that up front and called it
a day you know the fact that they did
six hours
just proves how insecure that how
overcompensating they are
and like i said it's enough to their
fans this is this is just the way to
operate but
we said i hope to god they sue ethan and
have to explain in a deposition why they
gave a 19 year old alcohol good point
yeah exactly if you sue their discovery
is probably not going to be very kind to
their or i don't even think it would get
to discover it will get thrown out
thrown out thrown out before that
but um i think that they're not dumb
enough to sue me so only yeah that's
just rolo that's just rolo tony is easy
he's like yo go [ __ ] your life up
it's easy for him to act tough you know
but the reality is that suing me for
defamation is not going to be a cakewalk
for you i promise
you'll burn these guys to the ground
you know
you know
the only thing you burn to the ground is
prune juice to keep regular
i'm just saying
the only thing you burn is that early
bird special dude
i'm just saying
i mean he's about to get his uh
5.99 denny's uh senior meals that's all
i'm saying what's that organization for
retired people
uh aarp yeah you're about dude you're
bro come on
you're about to join aarp so don't talk
about
burning people to the ground
don't think burning is your [ __ ]
cadaver when you're
past from old age basically is where i
was going after a happy long life yeah
we would never violence passing
peacefully in your sleep
then we will burn your someone will burn
your body an incinerator thank
you i thought this was this was kind of
my favorite moment was rolo tony
we see you rolo tony
rolo tony um
this dude
that fan made so badly
okay so this is something that came up
and it's so telling
just watch this and we'll talk about it
afterwards
okay
i was looking for toilet paper
in this man's bathroom because he
doesn't have any
so i opened this
this like big drawer because it wasn't
in the cabinets and [ __ ] look
should i be concerned yes or no
she dude he has boxes of plan b
that
tells a lot
that to me
how regularly are you needing plan b
dude
i mean
what uh well that is so disturbing
i mean that means he's basically nutting
in and side he's planning to nut inside
you
he's not planning on using uh protection
and if he has that much use for plan b
i would say
that is so [ __ ] up to have that much
plan i mean that guy has five plan b's
that's super creepy it's so weird it's
so [ __ ] weird
maybe try plan a next time
right you won't need
you know like it maybe having one is
handy yeah i mean it's still a little
weird little but five boxes of plan b
dude you [ __ ] you
you're disturbing me
and this is the guy who
you know
listen who do you believe the guy with
five plan b's in his drawer
no
[ __ ] no
and you know it's so i find it so
interesting that
this guy this chauvinistic [ __ ] he's so
happy to give plan b to the women
plan b supercharges the woman's body
with hormones so like avoid getting
pregnant and it is a heavy for the
ladies it's hard on the body
and i don't know how healthy it is i
know it's safe to take but it's
it's so [ __ ] easy for him to be like
yo take this when he doesn't have to
deal with the consequence of it just
wear a condom you [ __ ] freak
coerce sex that's what that speaks to me
oh my god
i can't get over that man
uh is this really a rolo tony thing uh
that's what cam said
yeah i found it on his twitter is that
what he looks like he looks so [ __ ]
old in that
he looks older than my dad
it's straight up uh
aarp magazine cover
yeah yeah 100
rollo you know you think you look cool
you just look old as [ __ ] bro you should
be talking about bingo strategy and [ __ ]
not about picking up chicks
like how good are you at like uh craps
and stuff like that
i could feel roller read this five-star
review of the
he wrote a book
can you scroll down dan rational mail
okay so this is a review of his book i
could feel rollo's compassion for the
guy's experience in every part of the
book roller was like a doctor who tells
the patient things exactly how they are
hiding nothing and more than that laying
out all the intimate details of his
experience which got the patient
to this point yeah uh rolo just ruined
your life bro
you just polluted your brain i feel like
he wrote that about himself oh for sure
look at you man
holy [ __ ]
i'm just taking it here's an honest
review here's a one star review the only
people this book will help and thus
targets is young lonely teenage boys who
have nobody else to ask possibly don't
know how to talk to girls and look at
the entire gender as the other that's so
true like the way these guys talk about
women is that it's like a monolith like
every girl is the [ __ ] same it's
literally like middle school mentality
like i thought like that when i was 11
years old yeah you're
full of cheesy one-liners and stereo
types like if she doesn't sleep with you
on the fifth date leave or if you won't
marry her in six months don't move in or
the best never tell her how many women
you slept with this book literally is
just click bait for
with absolutely no actual advice on
gender dynamics or relationships
that was a hater for sure written eight
months ago before i ever talked about
this guy
i got one more review i just sent pretty
simple oh yeah let's do it rolo tone of
the greatest writer of our generation
i like when all any of these advices lie
lie to women
like just lie to women never be truthful
women like what the [ __ ]
that's terrible advice
my brother got this book and i can
summarize it in a sentence women are the
enemy men are oppressed this is the
incel 101 book to be honest yeah
ugh these dudes man hey it's kind of
epic
all these fresh and fit fans keep uh
donating to
like they're donating their message in
oh because they want to you know send
send a chat so thanks for the money wait
go ahead and read it anything good
i believe him because you made us watch
the six-hour pod for you
who's you
and then you skipped fnf debunking her
okay you're a [ __ ] liar i literally
said
don't watch their stream so you're not
you're a fake fan busted you're avoiding
the abba and preach vid we're aware of
the ab and preach thing who cares
they're a third party they're not
involved we're just talking about fresh
and fit
yeah that's fair that's that's a good
assessment i mean who cares i mean
people talk about stuff we talk about on
the show all the time i don't need to we
need to we need to watch every uh
reaction to reaction vid look they have
their opinion i i frankly haven't
watched the video they have their
opinion
but like dan said they're not in the
they're not in the conversation and i'm
just addressing fresh and fit
um so there you have it um
but keep donating
yeah thank you
uh
keep sending that money we'll keep
we'll keep uh ignoring your message
fresh on what do i do
if a girl doesn't want to have sex with
you
oh man that's a tough one
to do if you ever grow your place and
she says no i don't want to have sex
cool no problem i respect your
boundaries but but oh no
there's no butt that's the end of the
video cool that's no problem but
you're gonna pull out your phone get up
and walk into another room you're going
to either call another girl or pretend
you're talking to another girl then
you're gonna come back out and tell her
hey listen it was nice hanging out with
you but you gotta go now and then you
let her mind race thinking oh this guy
really just called another girl just now
dude you're 35 when are you gonna grow
the [ __ ] up
like be a man and actually try to
connect with people
this is so pathetic this line of
thinking is just utterly insane
um
that will never work by the way either
like you think you're doing some jedi
mind tricks you're just just okay just
be authentic bro
imagine trying no wonder they're so
angry like imagine you're you're trying
to do it just be authentic man it's so
much easier
one that gets duped into like [ __ ]
someone because they did some [ __ ] like
that they're not they're not happy
regardless okay like are you crazy who
would this work on why would this why
would you want this to work
exactly
at weston caleb when this guy is saying
this [ __ ] and getting paid to say this
[ __ ] dude y'all are a bunch of dumbass
exactly
he made a good point it's like why would
you want that to work why do you want to
have sex with somebody who doesn't want
to have sex with you
literally
you're gonna [ __ ] die someday and
what does it matter how many pulls you
put your penis in like it's so [ __ ]
meaningless in the scope of life dude
like holy [ __ ] man
get a grip on reality
anyway
that's about it eh
i don't know if uh yes sir
yeah i'm not i'm not gonna watch that
seven hour podcast i can't yeah if you
wanted me to watch it you should have
done like an hour we would have watched
it seven hours the [ __ ] off no i mean
come on dude
this ain't this ain't [ __ ] uh lord of
the rings director's got [ __ ]
again if you had some sort of slam dunk
evidence of that just completely
debunked we would have seen it put it
put it in the first 10 minutes you know
i mean just yeah please maybe front load
that should have watched that from
members instead of the creator clash
it seems about the same length no i
can't do it it's longer it's longer it's
longer seven hours dude seven [ __ ]
hours you wait seven i thought it was
six i think it's seven look oh my god
whatever too long
somebody uh
donated you guys should find where he
says he doesn't care about a woman
coming to me it shows he doesn't care
about a sexual partner's pleasure or
comfort when engaging doesn't surprise
me how he treated the caller he clearly
doesn't care about uh
their comfort or desire to sleep with
him he just said as much
says if she doesn't want to sleep with
you then try to try to [ __ ] with her
head and make her feel like insecure
then she'll [ __ ] you then she'll [ __ ]
you dude
okay how about just sear a second time
and make
and
you are [ __ ] in the head dude and
that's why you've never had a girlfriend
and even roller tony can't help you
because he's got to go to bed by five to
wake up and get that early bird
and i know you guys stay up late
that's when the college girls get drunk
yeah
i did learn a good piece of advice from
roller tony once though you did yeah if
you get to hometown buffet before four
yeah
it's only uh 4.99 instead of 7.99 oh for
real you learned that in roller tony's
book
that's good that's actually way better
advice than any of his dating [ __ ] also
um
apparently um
according to him prostate screening
after 50 is extremely important
that's true see that that's
that's information that men
need to hear absolutely if you're trying
to say save men lives check that
prostate gentlemen yep
that's the thank you rolo
um
roll is the type of dude be like i'm not
getting a finger in my butt that shit's
gay and then dies of colon cancer
you know what i'm saying
yeah
wow a lot of
a lot of messages getting stuck
um
there you have it folks it is what it is
i mean nobody's mind's getting changed
here you know but i thought it was
interesting i think people should know
that this dude has five plan b's in his
drawer i'm just saying i mean it
definitely says something out about a
person
new aarp hey rolo tony's on the cover of
aarp best this this is exciting best
expat tour spots in thailand oh red flag
major red flag
oh [ __ ] rollo no
really thailand bro
that's a red flag bro cam said lol 36
don't get a finger in your butt
that's
36.
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] these guys are such clowns man
it's fun
it's a good time isn't it fox
by the way love that he didn't have
toilet paper in his bathroom either when
he regularly has like hordes of women
over for the show
it's great says a lot just saying
all right should we move on now
yes
we should
thank you
ace fest tickets are back on sale
this is exciting
against all odds they managed to get
more up it's coming up soon we didn't
think it was possible
uh july 9th whoa mama i can't wait for
this
no refund refund policy none no refunds
[ __ ]
oh they changed the rules before there
was a refund option yeah well and also
sam pointed out
this is on event right now remember how
when we bought tickets and yeah it was
like a
shopify
website that they had set up themselves
so um i don't know how that's going to
work with our tickets
like wait we don't even have tickets
right like they never actually sent a
ticket you have a receipt you have a
receipt
about this event ace family is a one day
festival blah blah blah it says his
ticket sales are final no refunds will
be issued for any ticket purchased after
may 9th that's the day it went on sale
that's
seven days ago
bloodbor island
tags things to do in lancaster i think
you'd be the first person to ever ask
google that
there's there's a few things to do in
lancaster
but i it's funny to see that in the seo
uh they're honest about the location of
the festival
what where did they originally say it
was they said it was in
uh i don't know somewhere closer than
lancaster sounded a lot better
yeah i think they said palmdale but i
noticed that
i don't remember what it was before but
now it's lancaster
so
in reality
you guys got scammed dude i am so
freaking excited for this
37 followers
let's see same great prices
as before oh what's this only 145.
so if you want to go by yourself
for some [ __ ] weird-ass reason
i love that idea of someone going to
themselves it's just so beautiful
free autograph poster
guaranteed meet and greet dude how are
you guaranteeing that
if as many people are coming as they say
like 3 500
there's no [ __ ] way he's gonna meet
them all it's a group photo you get like
300 people in there
big wide photo
um
ace family club pass single
another single option
allows you general admission oh this
doesn't come with the goodies
so you pay 25 bucks for a meet and greet
and a signed poster and all this other
[ __ ]
sauce
well let's just
keep our eyes on the prize i'm super
excited for that event
and uh
i just can't wait
i really can't
you know in honor of winning the lawsuit
against rank kavanaugh's attempt
to remove our beautiful website
does ryan kavanaugh look like harvey
weinstein.com there's a couple of new
features on here i wanted to bring your
guys's attention to
one
is that
did we move this section up love or i
guess not
but there's a
there's a new game
developed by the wonderful people over
at uh
what's the name of the a blue pig studio
yeah shout out to blue pin studio hey
somebody seen this guy made a game
and uh what is it but is this the right
game
yeah so make sure you refresh the page
once
yeah own your skills
yep so there's added stages in the game
caught anybody coming out of the house
yet but you know let's see if you start
to spend time she's not okay here we go
don't mute this song
[Music]
oh that song is badass yeah why would we
mute that so wait that's harvey
weinstein
wait i got it wrong
yeah i think so
okay
this one's ryan what after all this time
i'm still not getting it
wet and reckless bonus
okay oh [ __ ]
okay wait that's hard no it's ryan what
the [ __ ]
damn
it was because it was moving
yeah yeah okay this one's definitely
harvey weinstein oh my god you gotta be
kidding me
after all this time whoa
this is this is important ethan very
important gotta nail this one okay oh
[ __ ] i think it's ryan okay i got the
flipped bonus you currently have the
high score score off anyone playing on
this website of negative 35
yeah
okay [ __ ] so so flipped bonus uh ryan oh
[ __ ] dude
this is so hard
we should have a scoreboard eh
could we do that
uh
no
it's super hard it's going to be hard to
implement maybe
oh wait lawsuit oh is this the new uh
cyber squatting what is happening
it's lawsuit attack system i think
oh
yeah yeah yeah we gotta get all we gotta
stop we gotta stop the points go go go
go go go my mouse is not the best oh
click faster ethan come on
this is a track pad and it's not the
best so forgive me
but we're stopping the lawsuit bro
it's we're stopping the lawsuits guys uh
defamation tortures interference
come on
come on
copyright infringement
this is hard
yeah this is a very hard level
[ __ ] we got out of there we're running
out of time out of the negatives
oh [ __ ]
wow sick
dude so was that the new that was the
new content was the lawsuit attack oh no
another one oh wow
yeah so
you're having right now yeah
so if you guys want to go
try out the new game make sure to go to
does ryan kavanagh look like carvings
but remember
the easiest way to reach the site is
just to type
it's a long url yeah it's really long
you don't want to make a typo so the
easiest way to reach the site the way
that i recommend is to type rank
kavanaugh into google or whatever search
engine it's number one yeah i see it's
number one today
it's great and so you have a good day
so what you want to do is go click from
there that's the way to do it and uh
spend some time reading up on all this
and yeah
you know play the game
and additionally additionally please
click on the
create or the person who helped me make
this game or actually made the majority
of it
please click his
links right below there he has some
steam games he has some twitter stuff
wait where are they uh just the buttons
on next to next to the link of these oh
yeah check out blue pin studio this
guy's awesome he made the game for us so
shout outs
shout out to ryan or harvey on twitter
too for helping ryan or harvey oh that
guy's great
yeah philly d took a little jab at
triller today in a video okay skinny
legend
boxing king
uh undisputed newsmen
uh greatest newsman of our time
phillyd
let's see what he had to say i sent the
link it
he said he didn't want to say too much
because he didn't want to end up in the
lawsuit with you
seriously
let's see
i also got to say just visually if you
compare and contrast this event with
trilogy a graphic not trying again the
ethan klein's lawsuit like you know what
funny
but
this has nothing to do with phillyd it
would be nice to have more creator
support i know i've said this before
nobody wants to get involved in this
everyone talks about how important fair
use is for creators this [ __ ] is
suing me
and nobody seems to wants to throw their
support in my corner
okay
as a big creator even came out in and
support of us that you can think of
um
maybe someone in the chat knows but
like it's a big [ __ ] deal
just as oh emily baker she's queen
obviously
yeah emily is a big supporter
but you know
um anyway let's watch phillyd
like creator clash looks so much better
also as far as the fighters literally
everyone on the card i want to give
props is that really from epic yeah that
was pretty much it yeah okay shadow i
like that
there you go why should phillyd be
scared to show a screenshot right
um that's what we're up against the
quartering did that says something to
you
when the quartering [ __ ] right the
quartering did the quartering actually
wait pewdiepie did i don't remember oh
yeah
yeah
remember live stream he made a brief
comment and showed some support but yeah
there's a lot there's probably a lot of
people who like briefly mentioned it and
showed some kind of support but you know
there's definitely not it's just the
first time there was so much
so much hubbub
um
and this time it's just as important i
mean it's even more egregious he's
literally legally harassing me it's
insane
what's happening
and you know it affects everybody big
time
i mean a lot of people at the event i
don't want to say names but a lot of
creators were saying they have respect
for you for sticking to your guns
oh that's nice i should've told them to
uh say that [ __ ] publicly
yeah it's okay i mean i appreciate it
like i said i understand that people
don't want to get in the crosshairs of a
psychotic billionaire yeah
you know because but yeah
um
people are saying hassan obviously i
mean hassan's the man
um and all all friends of the show
but um
what else we got here
how long we've been going dan
uh
2 40 almost yeah yeah 2 40. philly
interviewed dr mike maybe we should have
items on if he's available some sometime
this week uh i can
i could text him
he probably doesn't want to talk he
probably just wants to chill yeah that's
what i was thinking dr mike
i'll ask him to call in maybe because i
know he
moved
so um we got a few more things let's
keep going
we could just watch johnny depp reruns
oh
definitely
sounds awesome apparently she says she
did not [ __ ] in the bed
let's do that what is that so daniel
arena oh a tick tock pickup artist
yeah this was actually sent to me by
idubbbz
oh really yeah he sent me this to me
like yeah didn't you uh
didn't you comment on this in the in our
chat ethan
uh let me see i i i don't know
what happens when you approach a cute
girl in public excuse me
hi don't panic i'm not a crazy person
this is going to sound random but i
think you were super cute i had to
introduce myself
i'm sorry i said i think you were super
cute i had to introduce myself thank you
i'm daniel
nice to meet you does as i have a
boyfriend
good ones always do that's very nice to
meet you
rejection
seems respectful to be honest
so the thing is is that
that's the whole
tick tock channel is him getting him
rejected yeah well that's my man dude he
actually went up in followers whenever
ian first sent me he had like 500 now
he's at 2 000 but it's just a super
small account and he's just well listen
he's being respectful so
yeah i actually have no i mean it's a
little weird to film it but
yeah he was nice and that's really all i
want to see like he was polite he asked
do you have a boyfriend she said yes and
he politely left getting a lot of all
caps uh cringe in the chat
yeah that's not that should be invisible
he was nice [ __ ] i don't know like
remember the guys we looked at the hug i
don't know if you remember that old h3
video [ __ ] what was the guy's name
who sent ela dick pic
oh my god that guy used to do drills
where he would go up and hug women for
tents and then count to ten out loud you
know it gets way worse than this i'm
just saying
this video right
this was my first encounter with pickup
artists
and they used to be even crazier back in
the day because nobody was watching
yeah this is the video
this guy everyone loves hugs
he's telling his guys to get over your
anxiety go
and grab on to women
[Laughter]
wait i'm trying to find the part where
he demonstrates
but i'll say to his whatever i could say
i don't know if
we actually ended up having an amicable
not amicable but we like
it was very heated he was sending ela
dick pics and [ __ ]
of and he uses a minus pump so his [ __ ]
was like i guess he was trying to flex
it he has a big [ __ ] and that she would
want to be with him but his diplox
looked like a swollen [ __ ]
swelling organ because he pumps it oh
god
and he did it publicly on twitter but
you know we kind of squashed the beef a
little bit so like that back in the day
whenever we chit on someone i feel like
there was always a path to squashing the
beef
with people even though obviously what
he's doing is wild as [ __ ] and super
inappropriate
but like with the guys today it's just i
don't know it's a different
it's just different it's worse
i think you've just grown up
really if
if one of these guys sent a dick pic to
ela now you would be willing to uh
forgive that
look it was all good fun it's not the
day picked what it was just funny and
pathetic like
yeah
these guys are like and you know their
friend like this is the stakes are
different like they're friends with a
human trafficker literally well there is
that
um
we can call
oh he's doing fills tomorrow [ __ ] that
i'm canceling it
he says you want to come in person next
week
and i'm actually live so
live texting right now
um
anyway let's so so should i look at this
guy's channel it's just pure rejection
i like that we put some other ones
linked in the dock
extra chat rejection
i'll do this you got to respect the man
who posts his l's
yeah
what happens when you approach it
excuse me hi don't panic i'm not a crazy
person this is going to sound weird look
at the distance
this guy knows how to he's done he's
been rejected so many times by the way
it's kind of weird that he's like the
same script every time i thought i'm
like asking for gas money that's usually
what i hate yeah with that distance in
that posture yeah
excuse me ma'am i'm trying to catch a
bus back to uh
exactly my city i got stranded here my
car broke down they're my kids are super
cute i had introduced myself thank you
i'm danielle
hannah nice to meet you does hannah have
a boyfriend
good ones always do
why it was very nice to meet you
nice to meet you too yeah thank you for
being cool thank you coaching retention
normally
what happened
dude
it's getting bad it's getting pretty
cringy but i saw
i'm sorry
but what did he cut
what does what is too cringe for him he
met
[Laughter]
the the conversation with her she
i mean maybe it's just small talk it
seemed like yeah maybe there was
something right personal info in there
or something i don't know he seems nice
but i don't know it's just weird
i there's something very unsexy about
the way he's approaching them though in
my opinion
like the posture the body language
everything is just like crouched over
like a little gremlin it's just it's
just off i'm not crazy hey hey i swear
i'm not crazy and then i love how he
goes he goes oh my name's hannah so does
hannah have a boyfriend it reminds me of
uh that uk show the perfect gentleman
he'd ask if she had a girlfriend and
then if she said yes you'd kick her oh
yeah just [ __ ]
drop all of her [ __ ] yeah
sweet rejection this guy is kind of a
hero
this is the this is the red pill hero
that we deserve
what happens when you approach a cute
girl in public excuse me i think we know
after three times we know you get
rejected every time don't panic i'm not
a crazy person
this is gonna sound random but i think
you're super cute i had to introduce
myself thank you i'm daniel nice to meet
you nice to meet you
laura does have a boyfriend yes
the good ones always do
well thank you very much
it was very nice to meet you
[Laughter]
tim for me is the that he has the like
i just the whole pickup line thing where
you read the same [ __ ] line
see his bio on tick tock his bio on tick
tock let me read it
like i i feel like you should practice
if anything you should practice being
yourself and being genuine
so you don't run out of [ __ ] scripts
and then look
i mean
i guess you know
he's a guy who's
putting out content that's about you
know speaking to women and it's in a
respectful way and
trying to tell people it's okay to get
rejected i mean in a world full of fresh
and fits
this isn't the worst no he's
very respectful but
it is still
unbelievably cringe for some reason can
you guys find a w
where he succeeds i'm looking right now
all right so here's somebody's asking it
says over 40 and fearless okay what's
your age what do you mean over 40
you know what i mean
you're 49
is what that means
normalizing the approach find your arena
i mean he is a respectful king i'll say
that
and he may well be actually a nice guy
yeah somebody said w message l execution
that's a good way to put it yeah yes
here let's see he's looking jacked
stop
[Music]
i approached a cute girl in public
excuse me hi
don't panic i'm not a crazy person
this is going to sound random dude i
can't hear you say that line anymore
get you got it i mean the line obviously
doesn't work you're batting maybe
that a little bit bad
but i think you were super cute i had
introduced myself
thank you i'm daniel hi daniel what's
your name um
natalia this is how you have a boyfriend
i do
a good one
what all these girls have boyfriends
there is no chance but to be fair it's
nice that he gives them that out and
then when they say
he goes do you have a boyfriend so he
gives them an out
and then when they say yes he he
respects he respectfully leaves i mean
it's very good it's very it's very
uh
it's very nice to be honest yeah i feel
like opening with with uh i'm not a
crazy person
it sets the stage yeah it's just like
don't don't put that energy out there
even you know
but it is incredible everybody got to
say that every single one has a
girlfriend
so are they all elves
that's what we've all rejected
right now cam's looking through them
in public i think we got the answer to
that question don't panic i'm not a
crazy person that's fine this is going
to sound random okay oh they're so
nervous when he says that when he opens
with that
because then it's like what do you want
from me
yeah i would just remove that line
if i can workshop that with you a little
bit
and just say hey i'm sorry to approach
you like this
like that would be better than you know
hey i'm not a crazy person
hey don't worry i'm not going to stab
you like if somebody walks up to me and
says that hey hey don't worry i'm not
gonna ether you and take you back to my
apartment i'm immediately afraid that
i'm about to get stabbed if somebody
just randomly approaches me and opens
with that dude you gotta work on your
opener man it's not working super cute i
had to introduce myself oh thank you
tell me your name i'm daniel
i have a boyfriend he's actually hearing
their groceries
that was going to be my first question
nice to meet you
rejection is normally off it's [ __ ]
not just normal it's literally all it's
the way of life for you
but you know he is a sweet guy i think
it's important to say that
he's not putting
he's not putting anything bad into the
world that i can see so far
[Music]
oh wait every single video is rejection
everyone
seemingly first tic-tac approach here's
his first upload and again this guy has
39 likes so i kind of feel bad even
dunking on him so to speak
not even really dunking again i
i don't think the message is bad
it's just
i don't know there is something a little
odd about posting
50 videos of you getting rejected by
women to the internet yeah yeah
the wallets are turned off on this one
excuse me hi
don't panic i'm not a crazy person the
distance is sometimes an approach it's
clunky
like you can give this
this whole thing is wild
okay you know what tick-tock
[ __ ] mind i can't zoom in without it
tic-tac approach
maybe control plus
command plus excuse me it makes it
smaller don't panic it makes everything
with the video please it's gonna sound
random but i think you're super cute i
had to introduce myself
i'm daniel
does kelly have a boyfriend i do yeah
but i really appreciate it that's okay
the good ones usually do so
nice to meet you the good ones usually
this guy
the good ones you we should make a super
cut of him just going the good ones
usually do the good ones usually do
oh man
approach it's clunky excuse me hi yes
don't panic i'm not a crazy person dude
you've got to drop that one like why
aren't you workshopping this
you've got to adapt and overcome man
yeah right looming over them i saw a
comment saying that he learned this from
some pickup artist i'm trying to trace
it back to see if that's where he
actually got it from
i mean it could be and maybe that's why
he's sticking so close right
thinking
just be authentic man trust me
cute i had introduced myself
i'm daniel
[Music]
why is he doing this to himself
why is he going through this
the asking if they have a boyfriend part
two is so ultra cringe just because if
someone approached me like that
i would think okay so they're only going
to stop talking to me if i say yes i
have a boyfriend
because i don't know i feel like a lot
of guys
respect
like the man the male aspect they're
going to understand
[Music]
i used to do this i used to be like oh
no i have a boyfriend sorry but now i
just straight up i'm like i'm not
interested
like interesting that should be enough
to stop you i don't need to bring a guy
into the situation
as [ __ ] but that's a really good point
yeah that's a that's a really
interesting insight
but it's kind of it's kind of [ __ ] up
because if you go these women know if
you say
i'm just not interested you open a whole
can of worms because they don't they
don't respect you they respect the man
and you go
well i'm not interested i'm just not
interested and then well then it's like
why aren't you interested you know it
starts and you can piss them off maybe
they're psychic [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah it
seems like maybe it turns into a
confrontation yeah the presence of a
dude makes the like rejection easier to
take or something like that right yeah
wow
good insight that's a good point
[Music]
well hey you know what you know what i
think would help him if he approached
them from further away maybe
maybe from the opposite side
across the street hey
hey you there don't panic i don't
i don't have a gun i'm not crying
i'm not crazy but
are you single
oh my god he's getting further and
further away there's like a good 10 feet
between them pretty common so
thank you so much yeah no worries nice
to meet you but still fun bro that did
not look fun for anyone when they're not
100
on the market
excuse me excuse me hi
don't panic i'm not a crazy person
this is such a bad line this is going to
sound random but i think you were super
cute i had to introduce myself
i'm
[Music]
this is such a bad approach this is the
furthest he's gotten ethan we gotta see
where this leads this is such a [ __ ]
terrible approach because you go do you
have a boyfriend she says no
then he's like are you on the market
it's like dude how about talk to her a
little bit
because you're making it all
transactional like she says yes then
like you're supposed to just go [ __ ] or
something
does does many want to come back to my
house and sleep with me
it's like just just talk to her dude
question
yeah he's running down the sequence this
whole thing is just so well okay let's
see what she says
i'm working on myself too
oh there you go she did it she said i'm
working on myself right now sam
say that i i find that
people are like sort of in that middle
zone it's best to kind of honor them
where they're at so that they could you
know
be their best version of themselves so
as opposed to what
yeah look at him see he's still talking
all right
there you go he's like i find it best to
honor that instead of just [ __ ]
raping you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i mean seriously what's the middle
ground
every time
someone answers and takes a step closer
this guy dude this is not working you
talk to me i feel like i could coach
this guy
uh i don't know i can't help to think
that this dude has an alternative motive
he's recording it he's doing this like
every day well he is making something
weird up here i don't think like this is
a good thing this is a very bad thing in
my opinion it's just not genuine and
it's not working it's just it's just
it's he makes it sound so transactional
to jesus christ
nice to meet you
thank you for being very sweet and
letting me approach you bye
nice to meet you
but plenty out there who are 100
available i haven't found any yet yeah
i mean yeah are you sure i mean so far
it seems 100 unavailable lunchtime
approach excuse me hi
don't panic i'm not a crazy person
this is going to sound random but i
think you were super cute i had to
introduce myself
[Music]
i'm daniel
i hate how he talks about her like the
third person too
like he's not he's dehumanizing her yeah
like making her an odd on the market
she's like i don't have a boyfriend but
i saw you just put your camera down
about 10 feet away from me and aiming at
me as you walked away yeah
yeah that's the really bizarre thing is
that he has to set up these creep shots
it's a two-step process right he's
wearing a lab too by the way for sure oh
yeah yeah yeah
oh my god he also travels solo which
makes it even weirder
just this is his it's definitely getting
worse the more we watch
but you know this guy seems like a nice
guy he's been misled
in my opinion by these [ __ ] toxic red
pill freaks who are ruining an otherwise
nice guy who would have no problem
finding a girlfriend if he would just be
himself
that's the problem with these guys they
just
it's just the wrong path man
the good ones usually do so
it's nice to meet you thanks for being
cool yeah enjoy your lunch embrace the
process
[ __ ] walk straight over to my camera why
we ask if they're on the market
straight pick up the camera and leave
immediately
no drink he didn't buy a drink or
anything yeah
excuse me excuse me hi
don't panic that's okay don't panic i'm
not a crazy person this is gonna sound
random but i think you're super sounds
like he's about to do a magic trick or
something so this sounds random yeah but
check your shoe for a card
it's not that random bro drop the line
and introduce myself thank you
i'm daniel i'm karen hi karen this can
have a boyfriend
can you have a boyfriend
is karen on the market um
dude this is such a bad approach
you know
if he changed it i think he would if he
just changed his approach a little bit
sorry i was you like a month ago you got
to work on yourself right
i'm with you play with you well hey
thank you for
yeah my pleasure yeah my pleasure nice
to meet you because there are plenty out
there who are
keep approaching y'all
this guy has a zero percent success rate
it's [ __ ] incredible when they just
have their heart broken
i'm just fascinated i'm down the rabbit
one i can't look away
excuse me hi don't panic i'm not a crazy
person
this is gonna sound random but i think
you are super cute i had to introduce
myself wait say that again i said this
is gonna sound random yes but i think
you're super cute i had to introduce
myself oh thank you
you know what he should do
at this point
he should just say can i sit down and
talk to you for a moment i just want to
say hi you know three days ago
the whole boyfriend thing and
are you on the market thing it's just
the vibes are off you know what i mean
if you're like if you approach her
the thing is
it's already not genuine because you're
doing this like all day every day
but if you were going to approach a girl
randomly
if you had the inclination i would say
something like
you know i'm sorry to do you know i do i
don't i don't ever do this and i'm i'm
sorry to approach you this way but i
think you're really beautiful and i
wanted to say hi
can i sit down and then talk to her
but don't lie right because if you the
girl doesn't feel special if you [ __ ]
do this like boomhauer you guys remember
that king of the hill [ __ ]
if you do this all day every day then
the girl's gonna feel like a [ __ ]
idiot
because you're trying to make her feel
special and she's not
so like
if you say i don't do this every day
then
you know
somebody said fix him ethan before he
goes joker mode plea if call in dude
i'll talk to you
if you're out there contact us i want to
talk to you about your game um
i had ether uh a b
check his account because i was curious
so the first video on the account is
from march you said correct and the most
recent video is from three days ago so
since march
he's been slamming on this i want to
talk to this man i really do you know i
don't think he's lost i think he just
needs a little direction right yeah
perhaps zach just uh wrote in the chat
he said legendary sound bites here
yeah
by the way i didn't approach ella at the
at the uh
it wasn't like an approach okay we
started chatting and joking around there
or we we talked for the first time there
i wasn't like hey
responding to a comment was like this
coming from the guy picked up his wife
at the
holocaust museum
it wasn't like hey you're really
beautiful and i just wanted to uh hey i
don't want to creep you out but uh
how about this place huh
how about how about that holocaust how
about that hulk what do you think you're
like
i open up with yo this is all super
interesting i don't believe it though
didn't you uh cover passports when you
met her
where's my illa did i what cover
passports
cover package
like saying a cover of it
is what he's saying you sing her the
passport you brought her back to america
i don't understand the words that you're
saying
i'm trying to say it again
dan can you translate
what's he saying he was he was asking in
a joking manner you're familiar with the
musical artist r kelly he has this song
jail recently yeah yeah do you have your
passwords passports that made fun of
many times on this okay
so he was what did he say connection
that you saying a cover version of r
kelly who you have okay
as an opening you're saying i sang a
cover of that song to her that's right
thank you
i understand
do you have your passports
you'll be like yo you believe all this
[ __ ] man
you believe all the lies these people
tell this [ __ ] never happened that's
what i said to her
i believe i said i believe it but the
numbers are greatly exaggerated this
shit's all a hoax
anyway
brian yeah his brain had a boyfriend i
do not know his brain on the market
bro this ain't a choose your old
adventure dan be a human being and sit
down and talk to her
dude i was you like a month ago man
gotta work on yourself right yeah yeah
excuse me
look at this monster
[Laughter]
so gnarly when you actually see it like
that
[Music]
you know what
i want to save this man i gotta talk to
him
[Music]
free compliment hopefully it gives you a
little injection yeah you're welcome
free compliment free
give you a little yeah i i did look what
i did for you
dude just that's why he sticks to the
script so closely that's the first time
he went off and he's like talking about
injecting her with some [ __ ]
that's why you don't follow this [ __ ]
because you gotta at one point sit down
and talk to her and you're gonna [ __ ]
panic because you don't have a perfect
line
dude
[ __ ]
yeah i gotta figure him out we can
figure another approach another
boyfriend
another boyfriend man it's like they all
have boyfriends like statistically it's
just not possible
excuse me hi don't panic i'm not a crazy
person you need to watch yourself no no
this is going to sound random what you
say
don't panic i'm not a crazy person you
need to watch yourself no no
need me to watch your stuff
that's all hard
that's the hard way this is going to
sound random but i think you were super
cute i had to introduce myself thank you
i'm danielle
alexis does it like a boyfriend
yes
the way he dips so fast out of there
man
yeah this camera is really close to her
if this like a not
[Music]
a wireless available yeah mine's mine
works oh you know what he could be
recording on his phone and just syncing
it up yeah exactly he has two phones on
him
but look it's facing her and then he
goes right to pick it up remember the
goal is to fight he goes okay thanks
anyway
bye
should i stop watching where i can't
stop how not to film an approach
is this one where it gets outed oh [ __ ]
excuse me
okay it's just okay i'm not a crazy
person
this is gonna sound random but i think
you are super cute i had to introduce
myself i'm daniel um alexander doesn't
have a boyfriend
the good ones always there
well nice to meet you yeah nice to meet
you
but still
why didn't you think of trying something
else
dude has a rejection fat fetish or
something still fun though well what is
it einstein said insanity is doing the
same thing over and over and expecting
different results
when they don't swing from your side of
the plate
yo this girl said she lied and said
she's a lesbian
excuse me
hi don't panic i'm not a crazy person
this is going to sound random but i
think you were super cute i had to
introduce myself oh hi daniel nice to
see you nice to meet you what's your
name mary mary does mary have a
boyfriend uh no i have a girlfriend
this is not the first time this has
happened to me
dude
he just said i've done this so many
times
that
this is not the first time it's happened
to me
okay people are over it i mean i don't
know how many people are because it's
pretty great that's okay i know it is i
didn't mean any disrespect no no it's
okay so nice to meet you thank you for
being clear
it happens more often than you think
holy [ __ ]
when they're still recovering this is
the last one i promise they're past
excuse me yeah hi
don't panic i'm not a crazy person
you're totally fine this is going to
sound random
i had to introduce
nice to meet you nice to meet you
jacqueline does jackman have a boyfriend
no no is jacqueline on the market um
i'll be very honest not really so i just
went through a year ago a horrible
situation yeah
yeah a year ago
she's like listen uh you know i got my
heart broken a few years ago i can't do
this
okay that's enough but if you're out
there and you do happen to see this
we can help you dude trust me
okay
thank you
how long have we been going i got this
ezra miller thing and then we
go in three hours and
10 minutes wow we watched that for a
long time yep
should we do ezra miller or nah i
you are supposed to be home by
five o'clock these days i have strict uh
instructions
the ezra thing is it's not that good
it's 28 seconds
yeah who cares i mean the guy
whatever he just got arrested again yeah
well there you have it guys it's been a
bonanza
it's been a show sure has and um
thank you to everybody
thank you to our members thank you to
our sponsors thank you to the crew thank
you to god almighty who makes life
possible alhamdulillah
as are they saying hebrew uh
hashem
hashem
[Music]
that's a hebrew prayer beautiful
wow
um i'm just reading the chat
all right well we'll be back on
wednesday for johnny depp that's gonna
be such a fun experiment
the johnny depp special
we gotta go to the laboratory and figure
out the perfect title and thumbnail and
dude we're i bet you were going to get
like 200 000 viewers it's going to be
nuts you should dress up as jack sparrow
oh that's a fun idea
we should all do johnny i'll be edward
scissorhands we could all pick a
different journey
wait
that's
that's pretty funny
because if you're going through all
these streams we're already watching the
trial and there's one podcast and we're
all dressed up like johnny's most
characters we should definitely make
like pro johnny depp shirts and signs
and stuff just so the people coming you
know yeah because
it's insane right like you got to let
them know right hey we're team johnny
we're the good guys
you know
we don't you know just want we'll be on
the wrong side of this
jack sparrow that's awesome bro
sam what do you think you think we could
do that by wednesday
have costumes for everyone jack sparrow
yeah edward scissorhands
what's another iconic johnny depp
um
i don't know i'm going blank was he um
[Music]
willy wonka willy wonka yeah oh there
you go oh that's that's really song
that's
zach you hear that you'll be here on
wednesday we got to get you to zilli
zonk
so are we just canceling uh jimmy lee
no he can he can stop in but he's got to
make it quick
dan you can be fearing loathing johnny
depp
you already got the glasses
what about tonto didn't he play like a
native american yes he did that's
awesome
all right
wednesday baby you don't want to miss it
the mad hatter some people were saying
all right thanks guys we'll see you on
wednesday all right
[Music]
baby
[Music]
me
[Music]